[Musique]
dans votre 10
parce que
or ici
au fait vous
[Musique]
you salut tout le monde
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau match de ce pitch est ce un
match intéressant au possible puisqu'on
va avoir une belle opposition entre deux
hommes qui se sont peut rencontrer
donc c'est quelque chose d'assez nouveau
j'ai envie de dire avec les bonnes
aronian donc que vous connaissez
probablement tous ou presque qui est un
des meilleurs joueurs du monde et qui
fait partie du top niveau mondial depuis
maintenant plus d'une peut-être même
deux décennies un déjà il est là depuis
depuis longtemps et artemiev le petit
jeune qui monte qui avait éliminé de
l'histoire des échecs russe qui avait
éliminé
notre ami great chaud qu'au tour
précédent et donc qu'on est curieux de
voir sur un match contre aronian alors
est-ce que c'était une surprise kong
reach ou qui se prépare plutôt pour les
grands prix et les éventuels candidats
comme on a pu s'en rendre compte
ou finalement est ce que est ce qu'il va
confirmer ce soir on va voir on va voir
vous avez les caméras juste en dessous
les deux joueurs sont assis leeuwen
lumière bleue alors attendez pourquoi
auquel on est bon il va un petit j'ai un
petit soucis sur le temps alors attendez
il ya eu eu 4 de la part de l'even qui
est en train de rigoler vladislav
artemiev qui est aussi un petit moment
de doute avant de lancer le premier coup
de 4 c 5 avec trois décisions sicilienne
des cas tu comprends cavaliers prend
cavalia xi skies c3 alors à 6 nage d'or
valait f3 donc les jeunes qui jouent pas
le g3 de mathieu cornette il joue avec
trois dont 4,3 un coup là aussi très
logique qu'ils défendent plus de 4 et il
couvre la case g4 donc ça lui permettra
éventuellement de mettre le fond ou
trois sans pouvoir se faire toucher par
le cavalier et salut à tous dans le
chatt camo 21 sa du cndd screen of
claude louga 68
le site d'amd 2 donc systèmes chez venin
gains fawcett g4 alors les noirs vont re
ok ils vont accepter de prendre une
attaque allait droit mais ils vont aller
bien entendu contre attaquer al ldap
donc tout ça encore existe c'est du
grand classique car a lieu cinq menaces
cavaliers prend des 4 et cavaliers pros
f3 c'est justement pour cela que le fou
bien en deux le cas rémy qui prend des
quatre on va reprendre probablement du
fou mais la dame est possible aussi donc
un petit temps de réflexion pour le
joueur arméniens qui décide de prendre
finalement la dame dessin qui envoyait
on va viser éventuellement la case
c4est il va y avoir du damas 5-fu
bessette tour ses huit cavaliers c4 tout
ça c'est les plans très classique salua
marchandises 20-22 grand roque peut-être
comme damas cinq est jouable qui va
menacer des quatre aussi avec le pion à
deux en ligne de mire alors peut-être un
coup comme roi bien ici pour les blancs
afin de défendre ce pion à deux ça peut
être intéressant
on va voir ça lui a vite été saluer look
et what u ça lui a plutôt qu'aux dans le
chat vous êtes vous ne vous êtes pas
trompés 1 deux matches là ce soir à mon
humble avis ça va être un match sympa
les a joués tourbe et 8 avec les noirs
bouclés à 3 tours b 8 pardon j'avais
raté
j'avais raté le tour b 8 donc à trois
tours b huit cavaliers à deux d'accord
donc sur b4 il va reprendre et sur
cabaye et ses 6
il souhaite peut-être joué 1 dames c3 ou
quelque chose de cet ordre là
semble-t-il donc avait laissé six jouets
menace la dame dame c3 ça c'était
logique donc sur b4 il veut faire dame
france et 6 puis on prend à 3 et p3
probablement on va jeter un oeil mais
bon ça ça paraît de toute façon tous
match et noir peuvent pas sacrifier une
pièce comme ça il fait tout mais c'est
toi donc ils acceptent l'échangé dame en
a cinq
maintenant les dames sont échangées et
le fou de l'even arrivants b6 alors
qu'elle sait qu'à l'idée c'est que les
noirs ont aussi avoir des menaces avec
fou prend 4 mai fu c7
c'est exactement ce que j'étais en train
de me demander il envoie la kalach par
des cinq donc les vonn qui a réussi à
gagner une qualité dans la dans la mêlée
tactique avec le petit poucet 7 qui
faisait une double attaque enfin deux
variantes et la position semble assez
simple à transformer puisque la tour va
quand même avoir une belle carte
d'entrée en dix-sept d'ailleurs va
peut-être la mettre directement en 17
gagne un tempo sur le fou et il va
pouvoir échanger entre eux quatre mètres
la tour en d1 et ça va bien se passer
donc reprise et on va on va jouer avec
avec les blancs tourache peu hein ça
risque de bien se passer
salut à françois jacq salua super boomer
salua série de 85 74 salua parc à st
il a fait ces trois qui prend ses trois
bons l'acef wave 3 ses qualités de plus
après la perte de fou peut un peu joué
en partie longue ce serait complètement
fini en blitz il peut encore on s'en
remet fischer ii dans le chat en ligne
s'il peut encore larnack éventuellement
sur tours est de ckoi le peut-être
partira vers h3 faire un 5bet sert à
chasser la touriste qui peut aller en a
adacore surtout race est du coup il y
avait poussé 5 mais bon il aurait gagné
un temps sur le fou donc à y aurait pas
eu droit évident qu'il va essayer de
s'emparer du pion à 6 pour ensuite
pouvoir pousser ses pions
ça devrait gagner tranquillement fou
bessette
il enferme la tour et menaces pouces et
5 attention tout de même
on a toujours l'impression qu'avec les
blancs il devait voir une manière
d'empêcher tour c4 pour menacer tour c
'est trois des huit cavaliers eu quatre
menaces peut-être gagné ses 5 1 pour
réussir à échanger le fou f5 et c5
semble être une option faut quand même
regarder les fous des cinq qui peuvent
freiner quand il prend une fois en rêve
6 ça de toute façon on pouvait jouer
écarts et les c5 food et 5 à mon avis il
fait fou prend tout reprend à d'accord
et il veut envoyer les pions alors il va
faire f5 et il va peut-être essayer de
monter ensuite le roi vert des six parce
que j'imagine droit f2 pour les blancs
quand même pour venir colmater alors il
fait b 4 avec l'idée b5 qui on prend
tout reprend et jouer le clouage on
croit 17 il se dirige vers la case des
six c'était écrit d'avancé sur tours à
saint qui va faire trois des six quand
même
il trouve quand même dû contre eux je
hais le joueur russe
une ronde et 6
et il s'en prend à la tour et il prépare
f4f 3 enfin peut-être f 4 5 e 4 e 3 m3
pour ses 4,5 ce que tu veut peut-être
pas te faire fixer un si tu mets le pion
à f34 tu vas te prendre un rang et 3
fixateur donc il veut sûrement plutôt
essayé de mettre le lait pion avancé des
pions sur noir soutenue par le fou en
tout cas je dois dire que c'est plutôt
très bien joué de la part du joueur
russe qui réussit tout de même à poser
des problèmes dans une position qui
semblait perdu genre c'est un truc
marrant hein qui pourra voir cf trois
rois des droits des deux f 2 3e 2e et
détours et fuite qui pourrait éroder
donc là l'idée de l'even c'est que sur
f3 il veut faire croire que trois pour
se mettre dans le trou et empêcher toute
velléité noir donc j'imagine qu'il va
commencer par 4 puis maître laurent 1,5
éventuellement essayer de ramener la
tour ici de faire des échecs on va voir
comment il fait évoluer ses pions
peut-être sur e4 l'idée c'est tout
reprend bessette 3,4 en revanche de
supprimer les pions là maintenant il se
fait couper le roi ce qui est très
mauvaise nouvelle pour lui les bonnes
qui part tout raciste réussi à bloquer
droit qui pourra pas venir s'incruster
en cinq parts vers cet ours et c'est
tout là ça sent mauvais recettes c'était
bizarre on pensait plutôt qu' à repartir
vers vers 17 l'échec fait mal parce
qu'il va pouvoir jailliront à vii et
créent des menaces il commence par ces
quatre ils attaquent le fouillis pose
une question fouet cette la tour f 6 qui
joue sur le clouage peut-être fou g8
mais fou j'ai huit tours fc cheikh fait
mal aussi artemiev qui va s'incliner
même s'il a réussi à mettre une belle
défense bafoués cadre le problème de phù
cat c'est que maintenant le pion ne peut
plus bouger et on va venir avec les
blancs à vif rb6 temps il fait tout
russie soit il fixe le pion fx est
maintenant la seule chance et f3 tour
prend 1,5 et 2 alors le roi vient en
trois comme prévu tout à l'heure et
surtout refi 3 et 2 il va venir faire
office de bloqueurs alors est ce qu'on
peut
c'est chercher des problèmes autour des
8 peut-être tour des deux échecs pour
chercher quelque chose c'est bien joué
de la part du joueur russe tour j'ai
deux maintenant au f4 f2 mais il ya tout
huit matches il n'a pas le temps donc
fou j'ai six mais roy prend f3 leeuwen
qui est clinique i les cliniques
pourrait fuiter maintenant roi prend 2,4
et sur f2 tour f5 et a été suivie tours
fc est a minima et le pion f ne ne verra
jamais la promotion alors il a encore
tenté un piège c'est que ce roi des cats
et 35e 2 mais la roja prend et froid et
c'est l'option b qui file à dam notre
première victoire de l'even aronian qui
prend la tête dans ce match
il avait déjà fait mal alireza firoud
déjà dansé cadence là et on va souhaiter
artemiev qui réussissent à faire mieux
dans la deuxième partie qu'il laisse pas
le joueur arménien prendre prendre le
large dans ce match
ce serait quand même dommage de le
laisser s'envoler bonjour à marx alors
dans le chatt bonjour à toi
bonjour à toi donc on à ces genres de
réty avec le fou de foot b2 l'annoncé va
rentrer là on peut pas jouer avec gk
théâtre phou bessette qui est bien placé
et puis ça ferait pas trop sens le roi
noir n'a pas encore ok il est noir qui
vont sûrement joué ces cinq ils savaient
finalement un jour ou l'autre ça va
ressembler à des gangs idham tôt ou tard
par canon si je vous disais ouais et
bonsoir apple dans le tchat
ce coup-ci rameurs bourg côté d'arte et
vf demande au garçon ensuite il faut il
faudrait laisser lancé 1 1
à sondage taille et plus et fluo on a
tort qui vit en c1 on fixe bien le pion
c5 côté blanc et peut-être maintenant un
coup comme des cats peut être peut être
envisagée envisageable un straw poll
voilà merci cyril le ceo d'amd 8 et
maintenant peut-être dame b 1 dames 1
pour venir s'en prendre à ces diagonales
des plans classique artemiev qui sans
cette réforme ans position un peu
technique tous ces deux tours c'est un
qualificatif crée une menace en h2 il
est chassé ce qui va revenir vers eux 5
arrivant h2 pour pour pour créer des
échanges toute façon cette tour en n est
pas forcément bien placé mais artemiev
qui va se gagner la case c4 a au fur et
à mesure des échanges 7,4 sekkat si on
reste avec fous de cases noires chacun
tour ses quatre tours c'est à tour ces
deux dames c1 ça pourrait faire très mal
son assise rilov donc fou des cinq jouer
l'idée c'est que sur fou prend des cinq
on reprendrait 2e et on viendrait
regagner le contrôle de cette case c4
donc les noirs qui veulent pas se
laisser échangés après avoir comme qui
est français 4 jouable aussi mais il
prend il fait des quatre alors il va
transformer la structure de pions c'est
très bien joué dans le pion isolé et
maintenant sur ces 4 on va pouvoir
encaisser en c4 est sûre c'est prend des
on reprendrait du fou donc il va pouvoir
au moment souhaité jouer c'est prendre
des dépenses et 5 et jouer pour le pion
isolé et là il fait dame f5 très bien
joué de sa part l'appel casque pour la
dame 1 dans ses gants vidame lorsque le
pion aux kits puisqu'il vient il vient
directement attaqué latéralement le pion
des cinq attention aussi au four b2 qui
va pouvoir s'ouvrir sur le pion g72 les
bons alors est ce que demain il va faire
des princes et 5 direct ou est ce qu'il
va essayer de chercher de chercher mieux
peut-être un coup comme dame f3 aussi
qui menacerait cavaliers c4 ça peut être
une géométrie intéressante pour les
blancs une dame qui serait bien placées
dans dans la diagonale
on va voir comment le joueur sibérien
cib estiment elephant l'éléphant
sibérien variées alors il prend une foi
en ses singles qui va jouer le pion
isolé et on va voir ce qu'ils comptent
faire les fous prend g7 et ce qui marche
3 prend g7 à manger sain croyait fluide
à mach 6 3 e set
il semble que le roi noir réussissent à
bien revenir en tube est aussi roi h8
damev 6,3 g 8 et pas vraiment de
problème alors est-ce que côté blanc va
faire cavalier f3 les cinq cavaliers 4
éventuel ya le pion b3 aussi emprise
attention mais cavalia froid qui est
prend b3 cavaliers g5
on peut aussi avoir l'idée avec les
blancs d'oeufs le voyait d'envoyer
vraiment vraiment du lourd sur le roi
est sûre g6 damev 6 3 et 8 dames g7 ça
pourrait faire mal on va voir ce qui
décide et il joue tour s'est de plus
tranquille dans un style plus scolaire
il prend pas de risque il veut
éventuellement mètres la tour en c1 et
jouer un clouage sur la colonne s'est
donc positions plus qu'intéressantes
côté côté sibérien leeuwen qui va devoir
tout donner pour réussir
à défendre cette finale difficile
dan 17
donc il accepte pas les problèmes de
clouage et peut-être d'un f3 ici un pour
conserver la dame éventuellement menacer
des cinq éventuellement la dame prend
des cinq évidemment ne marcherait pas à
cause de fourrage deux échecs le
classique mais ça j'imagine que vous
l'avez tous vu donc ils acceptent les
changes des dames surtout en dix-sept il
veut faire tour c'est un probablement
mais peut-être tour c'est cette
attention tout de même pour prendre
cavaliers f3 du coup ils en profitent et
surtour ses sept tours prend des 5 alors
ça c'est intéressant pour ses 7 aces que
tout reprend des 5 mars ya peut-être qui
est trempé trois intermédiaires et oui
d'ailleurs il le joue et d'ailleurs il
le jouer bonsoir à hugo moreau
intéressant à cette partie qui se
développe petit à petit peut-être plutôt
bien sûr en faveur du joueur sibérien et
rentrer dans cette variante et rentrent
dans cette position qui semblait
critique
alors comment est-ce qu'il va continuer
en f1 va tenter d'aller capturer le
cavaly éventuellement on va voir f6 je
suis pas convaincu 1 de ce changement de
structure cotée blanc il a dû rater
quelque chose quelque part parce que ça
semble pas dans son être d'intérêt
d'être d'être entré dans cette position
alors amiens r2 il va venir vers détroit
mais les noms ont quand même ce pion b 4
ans le cavalier pas vraiment fermé en
plus sain et là maintenant il menace
pour ces deux échecs il ya quelque chose
qui s'est vraiment mal passé côté blanc
il était dominant
je met un petit coup d'ordi meiway alors
dit un avantage noir je ne rêve pas les
noirs ont clairement pris le dessus ici
je manquais mon favori pour le match
écoute je dirais quand même les bonnes
qui qui offre quand même de plus belle
garantie en tout cas sur le 5 puis 5 3 +
1 après en un plus un en plus ça on
verra donc
le tour à tour ces deux qui pourrait
arriver à tout moment avec ces
désagréables savez que c'est désagréable
pour se prendre un tour ces deux échecs
mais vraiment à tout moment et sur wade
3 pas exactement ce qu'ils voulaient
faire alors là qu'il prend des gars du
fer fou prend des 4025 qui bouge
beaucoup très expressif il est bien allé
bon
qui va les prendre en fou prend tout
reprend à 5 déjà une option 1 même si
avec un roi lion bleu faire gaffe à b3
mais a peut-être tour b5 ici avec un roi
blanc bien placé ça doit aller après
avoir un
il a pris et b3 direct alors ça c'est
une idée très vicieuse sur fou prend b2
menace dame donc tour des 1 et tours
c'est maintenant qu'ils coupent la
connexion et sur wade deux tours caen d1
reprend d1 et b1 dame obligé de repartir
avec fougue et 2 ça on avait raté à
l'analyse bon mais ça va pour les blancs
dans le sens où sûr pour ces deux tours
des deux fois cinq tours prend pions
prend on a roi des 3es ont réussi à
choper le pion donc il a fait tour ces
deux tours des deux tours ses quatre
tours détroit on va aller avec les
blancs s'emparer du pion b3 ça devrait
tenir leurs antennes prendre là nul
bêtement et pas s'embêter leeuwen
justement qu'ils proposent et j'ai même
envie de dire qui impose la nul à son
adversaire
donc maintenant le score est de 1-1 et
demi 1/2 leeuwen qui a résisté à une
position difficile
donc c'est une pause parti qui est
plutôt réussi côté arménien et le joueur
sibérien qui va jouer une une sicilienne
à 6 avec une transposition dans une
variante assez intéressante pour de la
lapine pour les blancs
après je suis pas un spécialiste mais je
sais que l'idée de
sur a6 de jouer ces trois c'est de se
dire qu'on aura joué une alpine avec le
coup à six qui sera on l'espère en tout
cas inutile
il vient de prendre en ces cinq dames
français 5 fu trois dames c'est 7 mai
donc on voit que le placement de pièces
noires temps à tenter d'expliquer le
quoi si ce jeu qu'avec la dame ans et
c'est ton c'est vrai que face à
structure là avec la cie c'est plutôt
logique ce qu'on empêchera b5 les
joueurs échangent les dames et donc on
va parler de cette finale immédiatement
qui doit être quand même bien
avantageuse pour les blancs on a la
majorité allèles dame davantage de
développement on peut peut-être même
développé par g3 fou j'ai de ce fou pour
venir braqué les deux fous sur sur cette
aile dames et puis envoyé les pions 3
compte de ces forcément dans l'intérêt
des blancs de jouer à l'aide dame dans
ces structures où on a 3 v 2 et 4 v3 de
l'autre côté les noirs veulent plutôt
poussé au centre et à l'est le droit et
les noirs veulent plutôt poussé à l'el
dames c'est logique
comme toujours aux échecs on joue du
côté où on a un avantage matériel et la
halle avantages matériels hi
il existe grâce aux pions de plus de
chaque côté de l'échiquier les bons qui
a essayé de mettre le cavalier en c4 il
serait content de voir b5 arrivée
probablement ça avancerait un pion sur
une minorité ça permettrait de laminer
avec a4 et d'aller jouer par la suite
contre un pion isolé en a six la menace
des blancs ça semble être quand même
grand roque s'en prendre aux cavaliers
aussi ci peut même y avoir parfois des
tours prend des cinq qui avait les b 6
ça commence à chauffer côté sibérien à
noter aussi que sûr aussi sûr à tour des
cavaliers d'écart à l'aider si schiro
alors il a fait j'ai six aces avec
l'idée sur mon roc de faire un échec en
h61 échec au f5 et devenir par la suite
rockets ou pas d'ailleurs l'aps cure et
on prend des 5es et b6 mais peut-être
juste un coup comme tour des huit pour
tout couvrir donc g6 un coup assez malin
maintenant on peut peut-être joué juste
tour d un côté blanc voilà c'est ce qui
vient d'être jouée immédiatement fou
6 défend cavaliers g5 sept coups que
j'allais vous proposer pour s'en prendre
aux fous fous g7 et les noirs qui décide
de se laisser doubler les pions en 6 et
donc qu'ils acceptent d'avoir une
position inférieure la l'ouverture a été
largement dominée par le joueur
arméniens une nouvelle fois jeudi une
nouvelle fois une nouvelle fois avec les
blancs parce qu'avec les noirs c'est
plutôt le joueur russe qui avait pris
les devants mais mais mais mais mais il
n'avait pas réussi à conclure il s'était
même retrouvé finalement en difficulté
et donc ce début de match est vraiment
maintenant en faveur de l'even qui
montre aussi un petit peu la différence
entre ces joueurs du très très très haut
niveau et les jeunes loups aux dents
longues
l'élan les dents sont longues mais mais
il faudrait il faudra voir d'autres
trucs long les dents ne semble pas ne
semble pas suffire
alors il fait bessam écart a lieu trois
très bien joué puisque sur cavani prend
à croire maintenant y aura pions prend
1,3 on me now sera le cavalier mais
aussi un tas de découverte are you re a
encore tout reprend d un tour qu'en d1
mais regardez si on en vient là la paire
de fou la structure de pions c'est la
catastrophe
et c'est ce qui est en train d'arriver
assez la catastrophe côté sibérien c'est
peut-être sa seule chance
alors est-ce qui va jouer vous prendrez
un même pour mettre le fou en b3 à se
recycler par là où tout reprend d un
jouet sur la colonne ouverte
les deux sont possibles l'avantagent des
blancs est clair c'est vraiment une
partie une nouvelle fois très bien
maîtrisé du côté de l'even aronian gens
qui dans le chat jaune qui atteignait
bah écoute c'est un d un des grands
espoirs des échecs mondiaux il était et
est presque arrivée dans le top 15
mondial avant d'un pur baissé
donc la fée fou et 6 après foulée un peu
revenir avec full f3 éventuellement
c'est pas interdit
s'en prendre aux cavaliers tout cas pour
le moment
evian b3 les blancs une excellente
position
il ya un excellent avantage foulée 300
prend un petit peu au pion aux 6 il en
profite
il profite de ce pion finalement faible
c'est plutôt logique j'ai envie de dire
ne s'en prend à ceux pions et de m du
coup la pression sur les noirs donc
tourner vite jouée il vient prendre la
colonne des oeufs 4 prépare 5,3 g c'est
donc qu'ils sacrifient le pion de toute
façon il allait pas pour s'y accrocher
moment il empêche le 5 et tour des seins
alors il est peut-être une idée qu'on
n'a pas vu surprise en réussissent mais
après tout dans tous les cas ça change
pas grand chose il ya le roi qui va
monter et on va jouer sur le pion pas
ces allèles dame
donc ça semble
ça sent plutôt bien parti pour les
blancs rouges et 5 fu 1
il anticipe j'imagine le contournement
des pions et maintenant il va monter
droit petit à petit
il a fait carrière à kayes est pris à
quatre
il veut vite s'en prendre aux pions un
allèle dame là il a vraiment un avantage
dans cette position claire nette et sans
bavure n'y a pas deux il n'ya pas de
doute il va prendre probablement cavalli
eux sains car il menace qu'ils étaient 3
doit falloir couvrir à ils menacent
crise et 4 aussi fous ces deux clés c4
p3 est réussi il va réussir à tout
défendre quand même avec les blancs et
quand il va commencer à pouvoir mettre
la marche avant ça va faire mal c'est
pour ça qu'il fait à 5 mais peut-être
des cartes maintenant fait p 3 il se
garde b4 pour plus tard siph airwave de
roy eux deux en un roi et fabre 2 et
puis b4 par la suite il va se créer un
pion pas s'éloigner
il va essayer de faire comme gris tchouk
contre maxime va quand même falloir
avancer et mettre la marche avant d'une
manière x ou y fou des trois ilets cet
échange doit conserver la finale va être
gagnante
il va être le fou en b 5 alors sur wade
3 et cavaliers ou 5 le retour fou j'ai
trois c'est pour empêcher 3,5 j'imagine
justement et sur wade 3 toujours car l
ie 5 parce que vous prend 1,5 ce sera
une ou deux couleurs opposées
il réussit à venir contourner puisque
vous ces cinq était une erreur ils
échangent les pions et maintenant b4
ouais ça va filer doucement mais
sûrement un les blancs ont deux pions
passé liées alors là il veut sur ces
quatre cavaliers des six qui menacerait
beaucoup de choses on en croit des 3 et
bien non probablement h5 va avoir envoyé
deux contres
je h4 avec l'idée h 4g 4h trois tasses
n'y a pas trop le choix et il a réussi
le joueur le joueur sibérien à créer du
danger maintenant les blancs veulent fou
prend f7 j'imagine mais revenir avec le
roi est ce qu'ils ont le temps vous
prend au roi prend ses quatre gk3 2 sa
prise prise wife 3h de roy g2 une halte
en mai ce que c'est gagnant ça c'est une
autre question d'avoir commencé à
évoluer
et bien c'est justement la partie dès
lors qu'ils sont fous ces trois en
premier pour éviter les baies 5
il va ramener alors il va faire cinq
croit aussi sourit huit jeunes arrivent
à faire re ste croix aux six way le pion
au no 5 et peut-être pas si mal placé il
peut éviter un jour des fous ces sept
qui tendrait à venir c'est bien ce qu'il
a fait avec les noirs il a réussi à
clouer ici si le roi viande et roya h 3
h 2 h 1 et on voit mal comment les
blancs peuvent peuvent progresser
maintenant de faire garder ici c 'est
3,17 et peut-être par la suite il aura
comme idée roy ses 8,3 bessette fou des
quatre fous b6 je pense que c'est ce qui
va faire d'ailleurs il va peut-être même
être gagnant avec les noirs il va
peut-être même être gagnant regarder
avec vous ici sur un coup franc de toute
façon désolé pour l'erreur
il voudrait ramener le fou ici alors
qu'est ce qui se passe ou des droits ici
fou j'ai cinq baies 5 fu au 7 bis
6 ça fonctionne pas y'a pas moyen de
moyenner et la partie qui solde sur la
nuit loyer pas moyen de mettre le fond
en b si c'est de toute façon vous prends
ça ne fonctionnait pas mais après une
belle domination en début de match de la
part du joueur arménien le joueur russe
c'est la première fois on va lire qui
qui revient un peu dedans c'est première
premiers moments positifs du match pour
pour le sibérien en espérant bien
évidemment que ce ne soit pas le dernier
pour lui alors on nous joue un genre de
gambie dame finalement à coup l'inversé
ça pourrait ressembler avec le grand
concept chigot rina couleurs inversées
en revanche je raconte un peu n'importe
quoi donc position toujours aussi
intéressantes ainsi gorille lecavalier
en c3 je vous dis souvent que dans les
ouvertures à d4 d5 il est mal placé
parce que ils empêchent champions c'est
de participer au centre cependant à
[Musique]
cependant il va jouer avec grand roque
et donc c'est un petit peu un petit peu
différent il décide de garder le calice
et 3 en défense et on pose une question
de l'audi jachère est super série sur
les faits isolés mais il n'y a pas de
pgs qui seront disponibles je peux
commencer à faire moi même
ils seront disponibles le jojo mais on a
décidé d'attendre la sortie officielle
et même quelques mois avant de les
mettre en ligne à tout simplement parce
que si on les avait mis en ligne
directement
il aurait été massivement partager et
donc ça aurait été problématique
donc on a décidé d'un petit peu attendre
pour les pgm voilà la raison
alors qu'est ce qui se passe sur qui les
prend des 5
je rate quelque chose je vais être
l'ordi là parce que sa main il veut
faire damas 5-fu ces quatre noms mais il
a dû rater c'est pas possible non full
méca et sur fawcett se passer quoi
attendrir là je suis un peu surpris un
fois h3 et et qui prend des cinq qui
allait arriver avec les menaces de ce
côté là ok donc il a décidé de jouer
tout pour l'attak
donc il y avait poussé cadre du coup
pour défendre à de rock et maintenant il
va faire qu'il prend à qui et prendre un
café prend des quatre menaces la foulée
trois cavaliers prend à deux peut-être
trois baies inquiets beckham
mais bon le fou est un excellent
défenseur dans cette position il couvre
tout bien il peut pas être échangé il ya
des h5 g6 qui retarde son que l'attak
blanche est beaucoup plus rapide
ça va être très important pour pouvoir
thénia fisea de l'emporter cavaliers f6
échec inattendu bes a cédé beaucoup les
mecs ça c'est beau les mecs c'est pour
ça qu'on garde ce genre de match c'est
pour à des coups comme ça alors la prise
et forcé un peu ce qu'on a skié prend 17
alors à regarder g prend premiers jets
prend pour l'idée est claire c'est
bouger le fouet ces dames j'ai trois
dames g7 matt donc roi suite mais est ce
que c'est si grave dont j'ai un tour
j'ai huit fois ci ce qui est prévu 6 on
va voir ce qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
ce qu'il a fait c'est ce qu'il a fait et
je vois pas le mat pour les blancs
je vois pas le mat pour les blancs et
sur fourrages 6 direct alors ça semble
être plus fort mais cavaliers price is
attention n'y a pas d'âme g5 1 parce que
la dame à 5 veille au grain et surtout
prend elle fit on peut même jeu juste
vous prendre la fuite
on revient on couvrira avec fous j'ai 7
et les noirs s'en sortent pas mal
elle a fait cavalier preuve six comme
prévu et dessins des 5 c la pointe des 5
c la pointe on coupe la communication
entre la dame et les droits et on va
jouer le surnombre alors là c'est le
bordel les mecs beaucoup de coups sont
jouables mais bon il ya quand même une
menace donc un coup comme tour g8 qui
défendrait rendrai la pièce mais bon
c'est quand même une option mais est ce
qu'on a envie de regarder ses pions
prend en premier lieu dame g5 est-ce
qu'il ya moyen de faire quelque chose
ici y'a pas de fous des deux échecs
déviation et à tour prend il ya d'alger
set à memphis qui menace ça semble être
compromis
donc il a joué cavalier g4 alors ils
menacent la dame et le fouet la tour g1
magnifique avec l'idée sur cavaillé
prend 1,3 fou gsm 3g 8 épreuves 6 avec
le mat de pillsbury ou ou mat de deux
pôles morphy donc il a joué tour g8
intermédiaire à c'était joli tour g1
avec cette idée donc ils rient maintient
les menaces et les cases importantes
sont contrôlés pour le moment mais ce
qu'un tout comme dame f3 est
envisageable avec l'idée de venir
assister sur m6 mais peut-être assuré
carré lisse et e5
alors peut-être dame f4 plutôt pour
menacer
pour menacer pour moi c'est orange et 4
bêtement d'un f4 peut être une option
je vais pas leur dire donc j'en sais
rien est sûr qu'il réagisse évidemment
d'avc sein d'un f4 jouer salut à une
poupe irak ce qui est dit ça envoie du
lourd
ouais ça envoie du très lourd salut
abeline cause qui dit quel bordel
cyril les cavaliers le fou georges au
trot dans l'esprit d'un f4 c'est bien
joué on s'en prend vraiment qu'à rallier
g4 immédiat mal cavalier e 5 quand même
joué il vient il vient insisté sur la
couverture
sauf son cavalier maintenant l'idée
peut-être tout reprend ses quatre
menaces la dame effet fait péter toute
l' attaque assez bien joué ce qui a valu
à cinq quand même ça on l'avait pas vu
on s'était dit qu'avec damev quattron
s'immuniser contre cavale ie5 mais il
n'en est rien fu g5 maintenant il vient
recréer la menace fleuve 6 puisque sur
cavaliers prend lloret damev 6 on
continue le jeu sur cases noires côté
côté blanc paraît ce que est ce que tout
reprend ces quatre là il fait tout
reprendre et 5 et il va prendre ces
quatre maintenant commence par axis
intermédiaire j'ai passé bien jouer ou
pas en tout cas il a fait ça avec la
dame a pas trop de cases elle peut pas
aller en recettes
elle vend h5 mais maintenant tout
reprend ses 4 et maintenant les normes
bâle damas deux dames 1 ou attention
attention artemiev attention sa menace
de partout là il faut qu'ils créent
quelque chose mais les cavaliers
cavaliers impériaux rouaroua bien un peu
plus neutre
mais avait-il le choix il ya trois
pièces pour la tour les bonnes qu'il a
avec un coût précis à mon avis peu peut
faire mal
peut-être
ces trois d'ailleurs ces trois peut être
intéressant avec l'idée d'amener 4b
trois dames à 3 et je te matt est un fou
qui en plus veillerez au grain et sur
pions prend dame prend pour s'en prendre
aux pions c2 et préparé du tour b 4
échecs fous ces trois semble être un
point intéressant fou à trois aussi avec
un peu les mêmes idées voilà ça semble
durer fous ces trois jouets puis on
prend aux six dames b4 et c'en est fini
des espoirs à tour des huit échecs y en
avait encore 1 on la verra t il va faire
tout reprend j'ai quatre abstentions pas
cavalier prend le relais des rêves sept
matches mais surtout pranger quatre
tours reprend et il n'y a pas d'âme
prendre 5 puisque le fou ces trois
défend tous et surveille ça j'avais pas
vu du tout ce tour des 8,3 g7 la qui
sortait de nulle part mais mais blanc là
semblent un peu marquer le pas leur
attaque
leur attaque est simplement courte c'est
bien coordonnée connaît les bonnes il a
bien défendu
est ce qu'à manille ap si c'était
peut-être un peu la vente qu'on
regardait avec le fonds en b3 défensif
b3 damas à 3 c'est terminé
bien joué bien joué les bons bien joué
les bons qui a une belle une belle
partie ici est vraiment vraiment très
bien joué à l'est on est reparti avec la
sicilienne
on est même reparti avec la nage dorff
toujours la même variante toujours la
même variante il envoie g4 de nouveau
c'est bien joué notamment les prochains
matchs seront les 18 et 19 novembre
quarts de finale nepomniachi qu'on dit
will rain et maxime vachier lagrave le
19 contre wesley so qui sera bien
évidemment le gros choc
côté tricolore est un choc qui pourrait
qui pourrait être un petit peu compliqué
pour le français un wesley qui a montré
très belles choses dernièrement qui
pourrait qui pourrait être vraiment
dangereux
mais maxime mais maxime pourra utiliser
ce match de ce pitch est ce pour pour
reconstruire sa confiance après la
défaite difficile qu'on a vécu
avant-hier savais que c'était
c'était une défaite difficile à avaler
la contre contre alexander reach ou qu
elle a été avalée sait jamais une
mauvaise nouvelle une mauvaise nouvelle
à deux c'est pas une mauvaise nouvelle
d'avoir un match même si c'est un match
sur internet et que ça compte pas mais
d'avoir un match pour se remettre dans
le bain et reprendre la confiance je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
personnellement j'aime bien ce genre de
match
en cas de soucis à leurs bécanes qui a
été joué c'était logique jouer le
clouage et cavaliers à deux donc les
vents qui qui retarde le grand roque à
fond et qui est d'accord pour rejouer
cette finale pour le moment je trouve
quand même je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez n'hésitez pas à interagir dans le
dans le chat mais les bonnes et fait
quand même très grosse impression partie
précédente là il a quand même bien
défendu mais artemiev qui profite du
fait que la cades des cinq étaient
étaient vacantes n'étaient pas protégés
par don par par la tour pour pour venir
jouer des cinq jeunes à tanguy lebron à
lire très serein les arméniens joue aux
échecs en 300 ans après jésus christ
étudie à wild ce penthouse et superman
ici maxime devient binational ya moins
qu'ils veulent eux le temps à la wild
card web afin de devenir rue st alors
sur b prend alors pourquoi est-ce qu'il
n'a pas joué cavalier prends je vais
mettre le petit goût de turbines à cause
de roy f2 qui jouer sur le fait qu'on
soit des clous et et que ce soit les
noirs qui sont à présent de cloud et
même si c'était complètement jouable la
jouer dame c7 est maintenant grand roque
et c'est vrai que ses pions beckham va
plutôt servir de bouclier au noir ils
contrôlent la casa 5 et va falloir
vraiment se dépêcher côté noir pour
attaquer donc il envoie le pion des cats
c'est normal il va sûrement prendre une
fois en déca dévier la dame prend danger
5 et peut-être mettre le fond f6 ma foi
les amis rien n'est encore fait côté
côté côté peu côté partis foulée cinq
fois f6 et dames c5
il propose l'échangé d'amis fait il fait
le chantage à l échange
car est ce qu'on va faire un poil thème
b8 il refuse carrément les changes alors
ali continue un il fait veut vraiment
échanger ces dames est comme ça après il
aura peut-être avec 4,5 même peut-être
comme fou bessette ici un temps pied
dans damas est il veut vraiment garder
les dames sur l'échiquier
mais attention ne pas se prendre à eux
cinq bien times et un parce que 5
il ya foule c'est encore pour le moment
d'amd 4 ça peut être intéressant puisque
se cache un maître les pions sur noir
avec le fou de cases blanches ça ferait
un beau duo de pièces et e5 me paraît
être un coup aux candidats ici pour les
blancs j'ai pas dans le chatt là encore
ce que je couvrirai la finale du grand
prix great food à es9 au kof
ce n'est pas dans mon contrat en
revanche à tel-aviv s'il y a des parties
décisives
après l'élimination de maxime je les
suivrai bien entendu en direct
prochain grand prix qui aura lieu à
jérusalem est donc de 5 jouer faux cette
étape des cadres donc comme prévu
c'était le plus logique car les bonnes
qui avait bien entendu vu cette petite
manoeuvre tempo marques unilever d'un
monstre à milieu ouais ça avec ses 1
c'est un sacré monstre les bons dams et
maintenant il va falloir envoyer côté
blanc tour g1 ils commencent à se mettre
sur la colonne j'ai pris part d'amsc les
4 alors attention d'alger cats il
pourrait perdre le pion fait dame c3 il
va jouer avec 4 par la suite continue
son son chantage et par la suite il
jouera f4
alors la glace à prévoir de devoir
supporter un adversaire donné poma m ça
va être horrible ça lui échappe nous dit
le petit patapon dans le chat et oui ça
va être dur ainsi maxime ne réussit pas
à se qualifier par lui-même on va être
obligé de supporter les adversaires des
adversaires il salua florian mériaux
aussi dans le tchat
j'ai trois menaces mat ce qui a fait
retour prendra peut-être intermédiaires
dont j'aurais sûrement fou prend fait
fuiter peut-être janvier peut-être ce
que fout des trois peut être une idée
possible il a fait fouet f3
est-ce qu'on peut prendre en f3 et
prendre en d4
côté russe ça se regarde en tout cas
même si ça pourrait être dangereux pour
le roi c'est prendre le pion bécasse ça
permettrait d'obtenir du contre je il a
pris avec 3 il a fait assez et pas été
une deuxième motion soit contraint de
ces deux protagonistes et je crois pas à
louga on udine peau est moins dangereux
que mam et dans le tchat
écoute je suis pas sûr un scanner peau
est mieux classé au vélo je pense que
ces deux joueurs de roche que ce soit né
pauvre oumma mais ces deux joueurs qui
ont besoin de confiance pour bien jouer
et qu'ils peuvent réussir à faire
d'excellents tournoi comme des tournois
misérables et c'est peut-être ça qui est
un peu inquiétant c'est qu'il y en ait
deux temps que si inde et un sur deux
est en forme il peut facilement aller en
finale même si ma mais comme le souligne
du cul 0,47 ça fait un moment qu'il
n'est pas en forme mais il avait réussi
à se surpasser pour le pour le grand
prix à riga donc à voir en tout cas
maxime reste bien sûr et bien bien
entendu le clair favori mais il faudra
pas perdre dans les premiers tours pour
arriver jusqu'en 2000 au moins pour
avoir un semblant de de destin entre les
mains
et merci à vivre italien pour le sauve
avec twitch prime grand merci à toi
tonton il va jouer à 4 et cavaliers à
deux faits tout rus/kat je pensais qu'il
ferait tout re 4 pourtour b4 et jouer
sur le pion f
ce qui peut faire fou à 3 ici il le fait
et surtour détroit
l'idée c'est qu'il peut avoir des
matches du couloir à la fin genre qui
ont poussé un roi c'est un prise prise
prise prise prisé matelas haut il ya
plus de pions plus sain pour les blancs
c'est plutôt les noirs qui ont essayer
de la gagner celle-là surgissent estime
avoir agi 6 mai peut-être fuite du coup
peut-être g6 ici un coup équidés sur la
justice fait fuite pour aller essayer de
s'en prend à ce mec là peut être
intéressant et l'a fait roi et fuites
autour des 3 i couvre
pour ces huit cavaliers eux deux ils
s'en sort les vannes ou fawcett il va
réussir à réactiver son cavale eleven
qui va s'en sortir bien fini le premier
tour ça ira pour endel il sera sans
doute sur galfond nous n'avons jamais il
va pas forcément toujours avoir des
appareils mans en or comme ça golden
cash flow maxime qui jusqu'ici au grand
prix dans les deux premiers a vraiment
eu d'excellents appariement mais dans ce
grand prix là qui vient il peut très
bien aussi prendre un white laisse aux
1/4 yakine à un guy un mam et d'ailleurs
qui se rapprochent crois je crois pas
tête de série
il n'est pas obligé de jouer des mecs
faible là pour le moment les joueurs
qu'il a et qu'il a battu dans les
premiers tours
oui navarra et deux fois topalov c'était
plutôt un miracle un de jouer des
joueurs j'ai envie de dire si faible
même si tout est relatif alors cette fin
de partie
c'est passionnant il ya le cavalier il
ya mon avis des noirs sont mieux le roi
blanc est un peu dans les courants d'air
mais c'est vrai que la tour ans s est
aussi très dangereuse avec la tour f 5
le roi qui monte attention quand même
côté côté russe d'avoir laissé monter
droit comme ça c'est à double tranchant
d'un côté droit peut peut se trouve être
retrouvé mal mais d'un autre côté ce roi
est en train de mettre la pression une
pression de dingue sur son adversaire
alors est ce que maintenant tout point
f5 et jouable oui probablement cavaliers
premiers menacent g7 attention il prend
qui les congés c'est 3e set h6
lecavalier qui a du mal à ressortir
mais le roi est bien placé il va pouvoir
éventuellement soutenir le pion le
joueur sibérien qui décident d'échanger
les tours cavalli qui parent h5 3g 6
euros le cac valeo il repart angers
cette délicate puisqu'ils attaque le
pion aux six le pion h6 va tomber mais
cavalier va revenir entre 6 et
maintenant on va envoyer le pion c est
après ses sept les noirs seront obligés
de sacrifier et à la position n'est pas
tout à fait numéro e 4 encore h33 f3e
quatre échecs pour ag 3e trois cavaliers
des 5e deux cavalières quatre échecs et
cavaliers pros eux 2h de roy prend h2i
l'avez tous vu les bonnes et il s'en
sort bien joué à lui bonsoir algebris tu
es en body language et de lots 2300
euros beau très bien joué il a vu le roi
4 3 3 avec le quart eli qui revenait sur
le pion à eux il a eu le bon feeling et
c'est très bien joué de sa part et salua
clad pas dans ton avis sur le niveau en
bullet d'un mec comme les bonnes et bah
écoute pas terrible à mon avis là il va
avoir du mal ils avaient déjà beaucoup
souffert contre firoud déjà il devrait
encore souffrir contre cyber garder les
fangs il ne s'est pas entraîné plus que
ça et max je vois les deux chat en même
temps s est passé pas écho plus je vois
les deux chat en même temps simplement
on est en train de parler d'une chose
d'une autre
donc le temps de réagir de commenter la
finale et au c'était pas évident
alors on a ces systèmes un peu fermé
avec ce 4 5 kg 3 ça peut encore donner
des rock oz et non non j'ai les deux
chat dans le même château en fait ouais
je vois tous ok en d4 voir comment ça
évolue
[Musique]
ce qui va jouer un c3 provoqué la prison
eu 2 et préparé après être quatre ans
des quatre points 4 passes et 3
maintenant il faut qui repart vers à 7
je reviens tout comme f4 quoi qu'il en
soit mais bon c'est joué par le joueur
sibérien du coup jean client efficace
bien placé m6 pour éviter les f-5
logique aussi prend 1,7
bonsoir intériste heures dans le tchat
c'était des 4
grosse prise du centre quand même côté
côté sibérien leeuwen qui va devant vrai
grand roque tôt ou tard il a mis son
tuant h5 maintenant il peut avoir peur
de se prendre des marais de pions mais
b4 bessin qui peut arriver très vite
d'ailleurs pour arriver mamie médias
maljean 12h01 b4 ça ça peut ça peut
partir mais à lifou c4 encore peut
commencer par des cinq aussi mais ils
ouvrent le feu à cette tendance par
fouet 3 et plus plus âgé des cinq de la
part d' aronian puis on prend un pion
prend peut-être d'amd de ici dames c'est
un ouais encore mieux j'ai fait un petit
clin d'oeil à la tour et il veut faire d
eux et pouvoir reprendre de la dame en
u13 il pourra rebondir en ascète
éventuellement avec saddam
ça c'est un rebond avoir 17 et peut-être
puis on prend le 5 mai doit vouloir
jouer avec des quatre à un moment donné
il va jouer des quatre à mon avis à un
moment donné ouais il veut pas laisser
la dame rebondir dont tient un pion de
plus il ya déjà une première école pour
la louer ces genres l'école vous prendre
à me prendre à manger 5% prendre option
g7 ses protégés eux cinq une première
école c'est probablement l'école que
j'aurai choisi mais il faut un peu
regardé dame prend b2 mais bon tour b un
tour c'est un tu files les pions et
d'attac quoi tu fais dans mon projet
c'est peut-être fait tour d'y entasser
une deuxième école alors sur fou prend
1,3 ce qui veux pas me prendre 3 plutôt
dame prend des 1 pour prendre un tour
prend des seins et dames quelque part
des traces est d'ailleurs avec damas
huit am-dam ici qui arrive
bamba k d'accord il si on vous prend
tout reprend dams et 5 g 20 en l'air il
commence par b3 madame bouge et il
réussit pas à voir dame c5 maintenant
parce que ces contrôles et qui prend de
la tour et il fait à trois maintenant
c'est bien joué parce que du coup la
dame doit repartir en b6 on va pouvoir
jouer sur le clouage sait très bien
jouer d'un v6 dame ses trois tours des
huit tours d un essai très bien joué
ouais c'est fantastique
c'est beau ça prendre de la tour pour
faire à 3 parce que la seule case pour
protéger la tour c'est un c b6 il faut
être bon pour le voir un ça fouette ont
pour le voir je peux vous dire que c'est
pas c'est qu'en soit mb demande rafale
c'est le 19 du coup elle tour dès
maintenant et c'est pas ouvert à tout le
monde de voir ça il faut prendre ici ses
marques
fantastic
très très bien joué de la part de
artemiev
très bien de la part d' art nf il te
vient de le savoir mais sinon tu perdais
la tour en fait par exemple avec une
pièce de moins donc vais vraiment
vraiment jolies manoeuvres
je remonte le moment décisif de la
partie la dame des 4 il semble que ça
tienne pour les noirs mais il va prendre
des cats une première fois il va faire à
3 et la dame a plus de cases pour
protéger la tour d'après dam des six
dames c3 on menace la tour tour des 8,3
d1 on menace la tour et sur ses seins
qu'on va faire vous prendrez quatre
tours prend des quatre tours prend des 4
et le pion c'est peut pas intervenir
parce qu'il est cloué donc ça a été
vraiment magnifique séquence de la part
du russe qui va devoir encore la
terminer
même en les vannes acquis qui dans le
petit jeu comme ça semble un peu plus
fort que son adversaire tout de même
j'ai l'impression j'ai l'impression que
dans ce petit jeu de jambes c'est le
sait le joueur russe qui qui est
derrière
il semble que notre ami que notre ami
silane elephant soit vraiment derrière
quand il s'agit de jouer un peu les
magouilles on glisse même s'il fait des
belles séquences tactique eelv a réussi
à réanimer les vonn toujours dangereux
et regarder en dame prend aussi ce tour
d2 et il va réussir à mettre des deux
tours 2 ou pas un mais il n'est pas loin
de créer des vrais problèmes pourraient
peut-être faire un show 4 lé tour de
damas trois tours prend 1,4
il jouera sur le clouage à il et il est
fort ce livre on s'est précipité une
nouvelle fois arte n'y a fait il réussit
pas à gagner proprement ces parties
gagnantes
il n'a pas de bol parce que on pourrait
penser que dams et quatre tours de
prises prises six marche puisque la tour
revient pas après tour des deux sets
mais il ya roi c8 et le roi revient
dommage pour lui et donc il s'est mis
dans le dur
madame en f3 c'est peut-être bien joué
mais la finale deux pions est elle
vraiment gagnante ça en plus il peut
commencer paroisse et 8,3 bougé après
prendre en g2 est monté droit jusqu'au 6
bon assez vite peut-être affaire d'âme
f5 allait prendre perpète ta3 c6 est
plus fort du coup avec l'idée ton projet
de aux prochains essais joué et s'est
jouée par les bonnes
c'est incroyable s'il gagne ça allez
bonne voie il va bégayer il va bégayer
artemiev 3,17 maintenant que 6,3 prend
d'accord c'est l'idée du joueur du
joueur russe a quand même six échecs qui
peut permettre un paix rhdp dont
peut-être qu'il va revenir en bessette
et jouer la finale mais je crois que le
roi arrivant des quatre jusqu'à temps
juste à temps de froisser si ce rêve de
roide et 7 3 6 3 des 4 es à il envoie le
pion à s'intéressant surtout au deuil
adam prend des deux maintenant ton
commander 2 e set
l'idée dont je vous ai parlé
précédemment alors c'est pour ça qu'ils
enlèvent la tour il peut toujours pas
faire tour ces deux à cause de tam
français 2e set
ils essaient de d
arte légende du roi s'il veut la gagner
la forty mètres la tour en veut deux
qu'ils encaissent eux quatre au nom roi
a eu un
olala il a mis le roi fallait repartir
en géant maintenant il se fait menacer
le match de l'escalier des deux côtés oh
la la il perd il perd comme un poussin à
il a perdu comme un poussin artemiev
surtout à deux femmes est repartie
arrange bien évidemment avec le roi
peut-être que la dame pouvait la tenir
encore elle est bonne comment il a
retourné cette position qui était
vraiment complètement perdante mais j'ai
pas trop aimé le jeu artemiev qui avait
le fou de cases noires il aurait pu
faire flouer 3 un peu plus tôt dans la
partie
on va pas y revenir mais ils auraient pu
couvrir la casse des deux d'entrée de la
tour c elle fait mal celle là encore des
bons soirs tenco bonsoir on sort à toi
des riches heures qui seront du bon soir
david tweedie trop loin artemiev il a le
prénom qui va bien mais il manque le nom
cas difficiles en ce début de match les
bonnes qui semble vraiment au dessus
pour le moment
pour le moment on verra comment ça se
développe mais pour le moment il semble
il semble au dessus il semble plus fort
il semble beaucoup plus fort même jour
arménien donc là est ce que les gens
reconnaissent la structure de pions
aller dans le chat on va voir on va voir
les plus intelligents mars alors qu'il a
gagné 1 euro on va voir les plus malins
d'entre vous qui reconnaît la structure
de pions
à quoi ça pourrait ressembler quoi ils
échangent de vtc pas tout à fait pareil
mais c'est un genre 2 ac avec un astrov
je suis désespéré mahrouk si voix la
profonde qui vous l'ami qui vous l'a
bien mise samara auxi inversée ouais
alors inversé ou pas mais qui est plutôt
un mât roxy qu'on emploie dans l'est
indienne puisqu'on a le pion c'est alors
que dans le maroussi propre on aurait
plutôt le pion à eux deux vlad m'a dit
qu'il avait passé deux semaines enfermé
chez lui à analyser les mares auxi et il
m'a lâché une info il manie vaut mieux
jouer avec le pion de qu'avec le pion c
il m'a dit après être restée enfermée de
semaine chez moi avec mon petit carnet
je peux te le dire et là est peut-être
qu'il y ait des quatre intéressant à
voir ça peu rodé avec l'idée de de
proposer l'échangé dame et de prendre en
f3 sur échec pour comparer les pions
c2e2 salua mystère et boule de gomme
mystère et ou d'albums plus tôt ouais
ouais passé mais ça arrive à ben laden
de rester enfermé chez lui parfois
pendant quelques jours voire quelques
semaines pour analyser un type de
position c'est normal on n'attend pas on
n'atteint pas un niveau tel sans faire
des sacrifices
l'élève ça qu'on se le dise est en même
temps donc oui la veltins cavaliers c4
alors le problème des noirs des blancs
évidemment de cette structure de pions
c'est ce pion détroit et d'ailleurs est
ce qui peut se faire manger ou risquer
une découverte à base de 44 qui retard
pris sur
ces cinq là il faut kalia oui à la tour
des huit en l'air ça moi je calcule rep
adam prend des trois par papa reflet
méambly tu aurais pas le temps je
cherchais plutôt d enfermement de dames
à base de roi je sais exactement pour
préparer du g5 1 jour et me dire que
cette dame elle est un peu et un peu
nigel c'est un peu une dame hammer elle
a plus trop de cases la dame hammer et
on peut avoir l'idée de l'enfermer un
jour à voir on va voir s'il réussit
notre ami cybergun elephant
on a envie de parler un peu un peu
anglais de l'enfermer puis avoir des
fous et 6 d'amis 6f qu'adam g qu'attache
cinq noms tard brillante si aux coups
précédents je jette un coup d'oeil et
pas d'enfermement dame fouet le système
g3 f4eg cat way et manquer le fou c'est
donc il a fait d'amd 6 g4 qui ont francs
c'était pour se donner la 4g deux
parlements y tient et salua peter khoury
dans le tchat
je prends g4 ce tour qui vient de
s'ouvrir un comme toi f4 ici évidemment
intéressant pour faire touré fuite fous
ces 8 à 5
kadri ferme ce qui peut il faut vraiment
pour artemiev l'emporter maintenant et
revenir rapidement au score
il peut pas il peut pas se permettre de
laisser son adversaire s'échapper
faire tourner fuite elle fait ses 4 il
joue sur le fait que maintenant la dame
a des airs l'attendait avait plus
protégés parce que tout reprend 1,4 un
peu ici sur pions prend il ya dame prend
d un mais à tour prendre quatre
peut-être bon ça ferait jouer le fou
mais je sais pas je n'aurais jamais fait
ça en bis doit éviter beaucoup plus
logique ça la scuderia fabio temps des
fuites
et peut-être dame c5 qui va arriver
rapidement
alors comment est-ce qu'on perce parce
que qu'elle ait des 8 et une idée parce
que ce cavalier a plus trop de cazin
hilaire il est il un peu il est enfermé
par le pion c3 qui fait une focale et
peut-être caïds et 8 pour le pour le
faire jaillir vergès un qui part vers à
un cavalier amv elle révèle en a cinq
est-ce que ce cavalier va pas se
retrouver hors jeu finalement prendre sa
douche froide pour bladi saez karelia 5
aces qui a finalement pas être paître en
jeu c'est la mort est folle elle est mal
placée ce cavalier 1 il est loin du jeu
il est loin du jeu alors qu'il aurait pu
rebondir en des huit six f4 dame qui va
revenir en h1 h2 malsain cafu prend 1,4
encore l adam camirand h3 du coup c'est
forcé et oui à la reine francophone ce
soir bobby fischer annoncera qu'il a mis
le hand vallon à 5
il est mal placé 1
on en sait quelque chose
on en sait quelque chose il est mal
placé en a cinq
roy g2 est ce que ça i masculins règne
pas et je sais pas je sais pas dame b 6
mais il a plu davantage il joue avec une
pièce de moi maintenant ce cavalier
pourrait jaillir en russie 5 4 il serait
bien vous réussissez j'ai 5 mai mais non
food et cinq tours ici c'est dur si on
revenir aux quatre avec le fou ouais
c'est ce qui fait vraiment refaire venir
ce cavalier en jeu là pour artemiev qui
réussit tout de même à aarau pour
remettre un peu de liant dans sa
position
s'il réussit à refaire venir le cas à
faire revenir le cavalier par b cette c5
il sera vraiment bien
oui ce round on va voir cavaler f1 tour
des limites
il joue le pion détroit maintenant
beckham joue est prise en passant car il
prend b3 et c'est vrai qu'il a réussi à
ouais les pièces blanches ont pas assez
de liant il apparaissait a créé 2 contre
je il ya un an que le cavaliere entré en
jeu ça va faire mal le cahier qui
pourrait rebondir en c5 où il vend à 5
pour rebondir en c4 attention ne pas se
prendre un tour pranger 5
ce serait ballot il peut commencer par
des trois peut-être quand même s'est
jouée le fou reculer maintenant un petit
coup droit pour se sécuriser et donc
à voir cet avantage pour les noirs qui
va se va se maintenir ou f4 joué tour
quatre dames f6 car elles trois bons
fous j'ai cinq peut-être aux dents fous
les uns que préparer pour amener ce
cavalier enjeux foulée c'est de bien
jouer way g5 peu vrai juste prendre
angers 5 kg qu'apparaisse qui menacent
quelque chose cette prendre en g3
réinvente comme ça en prend 1,4 au
prochain ça commence à prendre forme
vous prend 1,4 qui on prend 4 h 5
ok petit piège d'un match 5 et cavani à
26,25 dame prend ainsi 3 g8 auquel ses
cadres passés par un souci là il ya une
vraie tour de plus maintenant peut-être
des deux cavaliers f 6-3 g7 qui a été
sept tours prend 17 dont il n'a rien
d'un match 6 bref cette âme h sets 3-6
d'un match 4 le retour émanant des deux
et tour des 3 et tout reprend 2,3 et
c'est gagné a laissé plutôt plutôt bien
de devoir artemiev un petit peu recoller
au score
il recolle ircon allait bien joué bien
vu de la part du russe qui a réussi à
stopper l'hémorragie est restée plus ou
moins à portée de fusil de son
adversaire en k2 en cas de krach addai
pourra toujours revenir de la part
d'arsenal il faut rester à portée de
fusil parce que ambühl est ensuite tout
peut arriver et donc il ne faut pas se
décourager la cadence bullet sera en
faveur
du joueur russe et donc il faut
absolument qu'ils s'accrochent un
maximum pour revenir puis en d4 le fois
ci ce qui marche le curieux de on va
faire tout revient à moins qu'on décide
de faire dépenser 5 en premier vous
prend et tourer ya peut-être froid et
froid dans ce cas la tour c1 alors eux
aussi candidats
puis on prend fou prend deux tours c'est
un pour jouer sur le carré lisse 6,6
peut être candidat aussi un effet d'âme
des uns le gène d'apposer leur nom
signifie quoi demande manie salvador ça
signifie grand maître ça signifie grand
maître c'est peut-être un détail pour
toi mais pour eux ça veut dire beaucoup
donc alain carré en d1 et une ouverture
qui n'a pas forcément été une grande
réussite pour les blancs tout assez
changeant des quatre peut-être prendre 2
aya peut-être faire qu'il prend des cats
vous prend des cas tu es fou prendre
deux intermédiaires dans cet ordre-là
égaliser complètement il reste neuf
minutes à jouer dans la cadence
il reste cette partie là à une autre ou
peut-être que cette partie là si c'est
une partie qui est parti pour durer
prends des quatre grands dégâts tête
vous prendre 2 avril veut carrément la
faire dans ce format pour menacer la
dame on ne sait pas si grave pour les
blanchissant il s'en est bien tirée
c'est je raconte un peu n'importe quoi
c'est un peu ma marque de fabrique 1
c'est un peu ma marque de fabrique
bref point de presse
this way ballottés vais faire [ __ ] en
d4 vous prend 1,2 et toute la compagnie
alors cette position elle est quand même
un peu mieux pour les blancs à mon sens
parce que le fou g2 est quand même cool
doit pas être grand chose mais le fou
j'ai donné quand même cool et couvre les
cartes blanches ça ça couvre les cases
noires après il faut réussir problème
section d'un bessette et à tour ses sept
dames 4 pour aller chercher un 4 à l'esa
vient d'être jouée par le joueur russe
d'un bep 2 bien jouer dam des deux alors
est ce qui peut faire flasher
c'est ce que fois je crois non fois je
remporterai kg 5
damak à tour c'est cette dent à 5
on fout des cinq d'accord alors c'est
intéressant parce que maintenant en fait
sur cahier ces cinq dames quelque part f
j'ai quatre peut-être dame prend il ya
des quatre sur dame g4 ça peut-être pas
marché ce qui a peut-être damas quatre
ici mais en gros l'idée c'est que le
fonds en d5 sur cavani c5 il défendra la
diagonal tour ces deux c'est pas idiot
non plus parce que maintenant sur fou
prend qui on prend il met la pression
sur f2
très intéressant c'est très très
intéressant est ce que tam g4 est une
possibilité comme le précise fillon
prend 1 et tours 17
pour éventuellement qu'on contre-attaqué
là dessus alors directement pas je ne
sais pas mais c'est dans cet esprit là
c'est intéressant très intéressant la
manière de jouer du joueur russe le
cavalier qui revient ces sept
surtout ces 4 il doit vouloir jouer
bessin mais la fjkm regarder tout
prendre ça n'a pas à marche pas fou et 4
du coup il gagne un tempo sur la tour
tour ces cinq interceptions en l'air ce
qui peut en profiter pour faire tourner
cette sous sa menace vraiment rien non
rien de rien non je ne menace rien
peut-être que c'est le cas et sur un
autre toujours en l'air iaf ou bien
aussi mais le fourbe et risque il est
pas un peu moche protégera à 2 mais bon
d'un f4 sur dame prend 1,2 d'avoir une
idée de fouine
très jean sérien cavagnoud 6 on va voir
tam des six
alors est-ce qu'on menace quelque chose
avec les blancs à une menace vous prend
h7 roi prend 1,7 et dame prend ensuite
assez mignon ça
alors qu'a lieu ici c'est ce que ça
protège tous
est-ce que qu'elle va lui aussi se
protège tout à m'en fous des cinq là
dessus les foulées saint curé tour des
huit peut-être note un petit coup de
turbines khary cissé en numéro deux la
turbine avec justin prend b6 verre
versez le coup joué
donc il n'y avait pas mieux et ce qui va
réussir a dit guy des avec a4 et jouer
sur une aile dans la broye bien jouer
protège tous fous en dessin qui veut
revenir vers ses 4 il sera super dense
et 4 les noirs qui souhaitent échanger
les dames et blanc qui peuvent échanger
et faire pousser 4 pourtour 17 voire
même fou pas n en fera aussi ça va être
un peu short il faut c4 au toit en
premier menace un ce n'était pas assez
fait pas de mal 3 8 pouces et 4 one ont
entouré huit tours des quatre peut-être
même temps autour des 4 sûrement
donc
sur 1 4
d'accord sur tour des huit tours prend b
4 à 3,6 il avait calculé avait un truc
que moi avec avec un clouage qui
marchait pas pour les blancs mais
tourcoing aussi ce joli surtout prend
des 5 tours 8 maths et sur qui on prend
fou prend et il ya des huit ans les
rames et c'est pas fini
mais bon si c'est fini ça gagne comme ça
donc si c'est fini c'est ce qui va se
passer et blanc qui devrait pouvoir la
gagner tranquille ou trash catrice irait
bien jouer pour passer s'est fixé sur
fion prend tout reprend et on ira
gratter h7
et c'est gagné pour artemiev qui recolle
il recolle à un point il reste une
minute vendant la cadence donc on va
jouer la dernière partie on va jouer
cette dernière partie et une dernière
sicilienne début de match difficile pour
le joueur russe mais qui réussissent a
bien recollé n'at il va pas il va pas
faire cavaliers ainsi c'est là nul alors
il assure qu'il prend ses six pardon
pour essayer de gratter après j'ai katia
d'un rêve de maths et je connais pas la
théorie ici mais est-ce que c'est pas un
problème
peut-être qu'il faut faire quand j'ai
accepté de me prends des quatre ça
paraît bizarre
toucs artemiev il joue pas mal mais là
ya pas assez de en l'air à la fin je
comprends pas ce que fait les vannes à
il veut dire que son carrier sortent
plus facilement
ok intéressant les jeunes qui est un
pion - mais le cavalier sans tête plus
facilement donc avoir un développement
rapide pour les noirs afin d'essayer de
vite mettre une tour en ces 8
donc les gens qui ont un pion plus une
meilleure structure mais le cavalier qui
a pas de case alors que le cavalier
blanc à la casse b6 pour s'en sortir il
n'a pas lâché un set vous le dites dans
le chat il n'a pas lâché notamment
filippini solide artemiev in appalaches
après un début difficile triki sur la
dernière partie est tout à fait il a
tenu là résisté il a prouvé qu'il existe
et il a prouvé qu'il était là et il
s'est pas laissée s'est pas laissé
abattre
le joueur russe sibérien il n'y a donc
pas que les dents longues vues si on est
tout à fait la fête fois je suis fou
j'ai c'est là il me met le roi sur des 1
c'est pas idiot ça ça lui permet de ne
plus couper la tour peut-être est aussi
le jouer sur le fait que le fonds peut
pas partir à cause de fou prend donc
maintenant il va leurs pions b3 mais
est-ce que c'est mieux que le roi soit
en d1 plutôt qu'en d2 je voudrais tout
de suite j'en sais rien
food et quatre pour faire bouger le
cavalier fait roi 17 pour ses 8
à première vue je préfère quand même les
noirs 1 à
mais bon passion pas sûr qu'ils aient
des 5.17 il va livrer 6 6 cavaliers sort
c'est finir
si sky force et c'est fini à la turquie
va venir ans et 8 mois on en arrive là
c'est ça le roi est moins bien place en
d1 mais comment faire sortir ce mec
c'est toute la question
faut faire sortir le soldat a pas le
soldat ryan mais bien le soldat acquis
et qui enfermés
prends pions prince dont ses trois
d'accord salaires et de gâteries fort
perfect épouse sarah foccart et il
réussit pas le faire sortir
du coup il sacrifie en b3 il va jouer
cette position
ce n'est pas une fourchette en b6
fourchette il y avait mais le problème
c'est que tu allais perdre le cavalier
donc ce n'était pas forcément efficace
efficace quoi acheter pas imiter jean
georges m malheureusement la tour qui
vient à eux deux une imitation de
dauphin mais les durs à faire cette
imitation de dauphin vlad l'a fait
vraiment bien
une plaque marrante de philippe qui vous
a écrit ci perd rien pour attendre
frais qu'on invite à nantes pour les
speechs s histoire avoir des vrais
dauphin
comment est-ce que j'ai l'impression que
c'est dur de progresser pour les deux
mais les blancs doivent être mieux parce
que si les noirs avancent ils vont se
faire attaquer
on va voir
t4 réussi c'est dangereux ça va ouvrir
le fou ça va bien se passer un tu penses
avec les noirs tu veux faire un stade du
court elle et blanc ont pas vraiment
d'endroit de rupture ça semble aller
plus ou moins saluer tuco asb dans le
chat mais ça semble plus ou moins
correct pour les deux joueurs la
position semble bon je jouerai plus tôt
avec les blancs 1 pièce quand même la
finale sans les tours artemiev qui veut
pas prendre le risque
c'est justement ce t-shirt et l'ajout
d'un cybercafé elle est pas mal
prémont pas le roi blanc vin pour le
monter ou aussi
fini par avancer son pion d'accord
on va voir on va voir ça tu fous b6
quand même acquis et de mètres la tour
ans et 700 que les blancs ont quand même
réussi un petit quelque chose parce que
fout b6 amena sera quand même tour ses
7es suroît huit tours ces huit trois des
sept tours des mythes mat
non je pense que les blancs sont
vraiment bien les pions les pions sont
bien arrêter leurs ouailles dans le bon
secteur at on pensé foulée si je pense
fo b6 aussi je passe vous avez eu des
échos sur l'ordi mais ça me semblait
gagne en tout cas les bonnes qui veut
vraiment reconstruire son avantage de
plus deux avec cette partie reprendre un
avantage plus confortable il va n'a pas
vu le trou sinon ils y seraient rentrés
tout à fait s'il avait vu le fou il
serait rentré le trou il serait rentré
avec le fou justement il serait
justement rentrée avec le fou donc m6
elle a peut-être fou eu des âmes menace
tout reprend à 6 tours prend et vous
prend b5 way i recul la tour il a
peut-être intérêt à y aller maintenant
fubicy ça paraît quand même très pénible
non pour 1,1 milliard à 8,3 f7 pascal
vion qui a bougé s'en est rendu compte
trop tard
il s'en est rendu compte trop tard a
lemon way est parti qui dure des parties
de bon niveau des parties intéressantes
ce qui va tenter food et 8 maintenant
par la suite m la tour en a 7 pour
mettre le foin des huit essayer de
s'emparer du pion de 7
ça peut être une idée bien évidemment
sur roy g3 y avait à sur why they have f
ou g 3 échecs fou j'ai trois échecs
roigé un tour à échec ferait fin forcé
et donc ils menacent plus il va n'a plus
fou prend b5 alors un vieux fou des huit
08 ici je pense pas qu'il allait mettre
le foin h4 il fait h5 intéressant puis
on prend qui on prend food et 8 x h 4
mais y'a pas j'ai trois lacs est très
pénible
peut-être sur g3 réfo f6 match fou des
cats attention mais le roi qui arrive en
g2 ça qui me faisait peur tour 1 4 un an
probablement il fait tourner deux échecs
tour à un média pas fou prend b5 à
tourbes et un roi j'ai deux noms se
marchait pas j'en sais rien les mecs
sains un peu étonnant là certains coups
j'ai dû rater des choses parce qu'à
certains coûts qui ont paru plus que
bizarre c'est bien joué ça a monté le
roi maintenant côté côté les bonnes
alors il veut couper par la case des
cinq tombes et cinq bien joué b trois
ont des vies la tour la partie qui
s'enflamme autour des 4 wife cinq tours
autour des 5
allez il a réussi à supprimer le pion
des cinq à sauver le roi mais rien n'est
encore fait pour libérer ni les fans ce
qui reste quand même dans le dur il
envoie le pion mais l'option recettes
qui tombe il va devoir prendre wife si
ce prêt moules à tours qui vend à cette
tour des quatre protège allez il faut
envoyer le pion né le furent acquis est
tombé il reste plus grand chose côté
côté sibérien ça tombe ça tombe mais il
envoie maintenant le roi à l'abordage
il va essayer de choper le pion par
derrière mais il va pas y arriver après
trois échecs ici et c'est fini les
bonnes qui rétablit un avantage de plus
2 qui est quand même assez mérité à la
vue de ce premier ces demandes match
bien joué de la part de lemon qui a été
bon dans le dans le petit jeu rapide ce
qui augure d'une suite match
intéressante pour le joueur arménien
donc on va faire une petite pause qui
s'impose avec une belle petite page de
pub
histoire de gagner un peu d'argent voilà
faut le savoir et on se retrouve dans
six petites minutes pour la suite du
match merci à tous de nous suivre et
match accroché qui tient toutes ses
promesses
les vols qui de toute façon on sera en
difficulté en bullet donc c'est un match
qui va être intéressant et passionnant a
tout de suite les mecs
à
[Musique]
les mecs je suis de retour même à s'il a
pu mais pas forcément terminée histoire
d'être bien sûr d'être là d'être là
d'être là votre retour
donc tu pas si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas assez le moment salut à
geoffroy allard alarcon marrant ton
pseudo
n'hésitez pas c'est la première fois que
vous êtes là et que vous suivez en
direct de m un petit like un petit
follow j'ai envie de dire ça fait
plaisir ça va bien se passer bien se
passer
t'inquiète pas t'inquiète pas mais un
petit follow ça va bien se passer bien
se passer mais ça fait pas de mal un
salut monsieur pessoa glisse avec un sav
tonton j'ai loupé beaucoup de choses je
viens juste de rentrer à la maison mais
a tout loupé j'ai envie de dire ne pas
ne sort plus de chez toi alors morgan
57,39 qui me saluent ces mots green 57
on est là tonton si si si si tonton toi
même tu sais quand est ce que les cours
en français sur thiès comme et je pense
vraiment bientôt avant la fin de l'année
j'en suis sûr ça devrait arriver très
rapidement même si j'ai beaucoup de ce
tri mais c'est difficile de terminer
complètement tu vois et des deux trois
petits problèmes techniques sur deux
trois vidéos malheureusement
mais bon quels sont les prix il faut
rechercher sur une chaise comme tu
quoque nuit karuna suez il a su et il a
su et il est monté sur scène il assuré
bonsoir un marois cindy bonsoir savourer
ma superbe voix tout au long des leçons
malheureusement ça a été traduit de
l'anglais on n'a pas pu trop bouger les
vidéos donc il ya quelques phrases en
français qui ont peut être vous paraître
un peu bizarre mais parce qu'il fallait
suivre le modèle qui avait donc c'est
pas facile de construire des phrases sur
une vidéo avec un timing très précis
mais c'est quand même bien nous paraît
télévision que les trois garçons ne sont
pas terminées pas sur les 3/4 si on a il
y en a deux de fait et je crois qu'il en
reste encore deux ou trois en fait
enfin deux ennemis et normalement ils
mettront en ligne à la fin ça devrait
aller ça devrait aller vite
malheureusement tu aie a de nouveau ce
pitch est le 18 le 19
la difficulté c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses je connais pas les dimensions de
de mon plateau des chèques gâteries
différents perfect je connais d'autres
dimensions
mais j'ai peur j'ai peur de me faire
strike et bonsoir à guillon pea qui dit
bonsoir de suisse des écoutes bonsoir
les levées si j'ai envie de dire tu es
dans quels comptes ont eu un mélange
peur de me faire trike après si on parle
dimension j'ai peur de femmes strike
non mais bon après elle benoît jouer le
19 contre aures les speed soit
rabatteurs qui nous dit mme ou je fais
un malheur
donc cette pause qui durent pas pourquoi
tu as tu des écoutes pub tue parce
qu'ils foutent onze pays arabes qui se
passe à gauche à droite tête je remets
ça du coup en enlevant la musique va
mettre un peu leurs tableaux donc voir
un match l'inca murat du dax sera chaud
dingli rennes nepomniachi ce sera chaud
ou sso mvele à mon avis ce sera très
chaud
là y'a que des chocs 1 il ya que des
chocs à mon avis tout des favoris après
de son quart de finale
hikaru qui tient pas sa diète
donc je vois bien une victoire du joueur
polonais s'il est concentré
salut azéri coco l'asticot bonsoir à
vous et je courrai dont vous quoi je
fais un accent ou les dents je suis
complètement malade sa c'est un gros
problème en fait pas les poulets etc à
rougé 10 à poulets non mais je dis
hikaru calme-toi reprend reprend la
diète reprend les prépas et puis gagne
nous quelque chose un petit peu quelque
chose
1ère partie
j'avais bien joué contre guéri mais d'où
ta joue bien je crois qu'il est il est
15e mondial il en train de monter un
bouddha c'est le petit jeune qui monte
qui monte un j'ai envie de dire il monte
le petit jeune qui monte
on va voir on verra duda à duda hikaru
et tout allait quand même favori après
on verra
mais à mon avis je pronostique une
victoire non surprise est logique de
duda est-ce que je commencerai le match
great food duda et non franchement
hikaru qui tient pas ça y est c'est
tabou dans un spa taboos pas tabou pas
tabou alors ciblé fente qui jouent
contre les bons b3 au premier quart et
les accises poupée deux des cinq ares
qui a joué avec 4,4 me méfie car ayant
en f3 diable aussi ses candidats n'a
cassé le 18 je crois à nantes où tanaka
c'est le match qu'on sait pas parce que
doute âge ou encore le grand prix et il
joue la finale
donc il n'a pas il n'y a pas communiqué
de date
qui va gagner entre toutes a écrite
choqué j'espère gritche aucun nom qui
vient à eux quatre c'est intéressant ce
qui a valu aux quatre parce que ça
empêche ça empêche le jeu puissant
allait droit et pourquoi ils allaient
prendre le temps des deux sachets pas
trop peut-être
4 il prend des 5
il va jouer tour il va jouer cavalier 5
et la tour c'est un rêve c'est bien non
mais ça c'est mieux pour les blancs
clairement quand tu feras tour c'est un
d'ailleurs fort à faire gaffe de passe
prendre dan c2 et qui sera une double
attaque
il y en a qui l'ont oublié ils ont eu
des problèmes
il n'a pas oublié
il va faire quoi il va faire car relief
sur tf6 qui a valu aux cinq pénible vis
et 6 donc il va faire h6 ou g6 un coup
comme h4 me paraît intéressant et fikara
ie5 quand même assez bien joué c'est
bien joué parce que quand il ya tout qui
s'échangent il prend ses 7 à la fin et
c'est la cata
ouais c'est dur là il peut y avoir de la
casse ces six foulées saint cloud qui
arrive et ça va jouer la case c6
peut-être f4 maintenant zhu cavalli c6
direct pouvait attendre aux siens
fu proche d'eux alors suroît g1 d'un
match 4 tours e1 damage deux roues en f1
dans ma chambre de dame g2 il ya
peut-être des toros roi kiro dont roy
j'ai trois dames g5 f4 tour prend 2,3
bon faut partir comme ça alors peut-être
qu'il fera tout rêve 6-1 savoir c'est
intéressant il a fait rager droit
d'alger c'est un gâchis 4 mai aip à
tourcoing 3 et de fer tour f3 et il a
calculé un coup plus loin ils sont forts
un meet our f3 d'un match 5 d'un match
en direct à oui puisque surtout machin
avait tout reprendre 3 donc cavaniol 5
qui est pro 3 d'un procès c'est trop
bien joué il menace d'armes preuve cette
attention et surtout 3e 5 f e dame gk3
f2 dame g20 à prendre 3 ou les amis
c'est très chaud
j'ai cinq défend f7 surprenant et oui le
truc m'attends pas faire dame prend
prise prise prise prises çà échec et ça
ne couvre tout tourache un vrai très
logique tourache 1 contre attaque la
dame donc prises avec quatre forcer la
dame ne pas aidé à mener 5-2 f7 donc qui
a rédigé quatre seul coup et roigé un
voyage à 9,5 aussi foot est roi
bien joué ouais il y avait sept en l'air
il ya tout en l'air là il va peut
prendre des cèdres et voilà c'est fini
il peut prendre h7 maintenant tu prends
9,7 et changer les dames s'ils le
souhaitent mais je conseille pas de le
faire fait tour c'est 8
ils continuent à échanger les pièces
leeuwen qui est finie 3g c'est ton
courage cette maths et c'est gagné
c'est bien joué c'est bien vrai et les
matchs sont toujours à 18 heures pour
répondre à wind par eto'o dans le tchat
donc non ce sera à 18 heures voilà ils
sont ils ont très bien joué là ça c'est
très très belle partie de la part du
joueur de la part du joueur je joueur
sibérien si charge aubry sibérien on est
pas on n'est pas rentré les amis qui
réalise pour le moment une très belle
performance
il tient tête
les bonnes début de match difficile les
bonnes qui qui faisait mal et puis petit
à petit il a réussi à à remonter et il
se retrouve de nouveau à un seul point
du leader fort voire ils sont 2000 à un
point du leader du coup mais il se
retrouve en un seul point du premier en
fout des 3 h f 5 g 4 logique il va
vouloir jouer lui aussi sur un fou des
trois intéressant et vous profite c'est
qu'il prend des cinq là elle a scellé
vonn qui a fait mal dans l'ouverture
là c'est les vonn qui a fait très mal
même dans l'ouverture même qu'il y ait
en b3 y avoir une tour en c1 tout ranger
non ça va être ça va être compliqué bien
qu'il ya un pion plus c'est ça ouais
c'est le cas et les noirs qui sont en
difficulté des 5ème tour g1 ici est
pénible à faire jesse sûrement il
préfère car allégé 5 par la suite
peut-être même comment ça crée des
menaces de dans best of 7
ça peut être ça peut être un coup ici
tour g1 est sûre vous aussi je pense le
problème s'était qualifié cet échec je
te le montrer et avec tam croît aussi ce
qui suit va voir quand il continue sur
ce b5
peut-être ne pas faire tout rejet
inquiets g5 à cause de cavalia a cinq
qui rouleront intermédiaire
donc la fête dame ces deux directs alors
ils menacent le cavalier c6 et le pion à
f/5 oui c'est assez logique aussi il
faut dire la question que je me pose
c'est ce que fout b4 échec peut être une
option pour provoquer cavaliers prendre
cavaliers prend menacé bouger prendre
des trois prendre des trois héros quai
et c'est ce qui va jouer d'ailleurs
il a dû le rater les voisins se fout des
quatre ce qu'il est en train de
réfléchir il fait qu'ali c3 du coup mais
bon c'est une concession maintenant il
ya petit rock étonnant étonnant comme je
veux dire quand je regarde avec la
turbine je le dis parce que je vois les
coûts et du conseil coudre a dit ce
n'est pas forcément évident autant là je
regarde regarde comme ça sans ordinateur
et nos fauves et 4 c'était quand même un
coup est assez visible
alors maintenant la position est bien
loin d'être finies les blancs qui ont
toujours un pion plus mais c'est moins
évident alors le fou qui vient bessette
c'est normal il veut s'en prendre à sa
latour ans et 8 kg 5 alors ils menacent
cavaliers aussi ci vise un peu cette
case là aussi vous prend ces trois
intermédiaires alors sur cavani aussi ce
qu'est ce qu'il veut jouer avec damas 5
et cavalli beckham prend à deux
peut-être des idées de ce type là les
blancs qui ont repris de la dame
sur cavaliers 5 je demandais ce qui
allait se passer je regardais dame b3
vêtements qui est prend des trois prises
et peut-être fou des cinq ici peut-être
même pas besoin d'amis 7
il veut faire h six cavaliers bouger et
fougueux 4 et l'invention que les noirs
une position beaucoup plus simple à
jouer
à moins que les blancs de 8,6 à faire
quelque chose rapidement un cavalier
aussi ce fou ou quatre qui prend un
foutoir tour 8 qui veut ils veulent
prendre angers7
bref cette qualité 5
ouais c'est bien joué ça peut-être dames
7 était pas peut-être fallait vraiment
faire food et 5 en premier pour pas
laisser ce cavalli rebondir c'est
intéressant aussi que cette tour son
emprise s'empêche d'un match 4 impasse
cas d'un prize est donc il est obligé de
reculer la tour et maintenant à 3 et
peut-être d'un mach 4 dames quelque part
non il se replace au centre à la
fouillade c'est logique il élimine le
cavalier et d'un mach 4 maintenant voilà
il a réussi à organiser tout bien comme
il faut pour aller chercher son contre
je mets les vont faire un truc très
malin avec sa tour allait il est obligé
de faire tourcoing f4 il peut faire plus
on prend aussi tout est protégé mais
attention le con tre jeu arrive c'est
pas en contrôle ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre
pourquoi d'alger site au tarif 5
ivey d'amiens où c'est bien joué ça il
veut a peut-être fait retour des 1 la
rapide hausse alors ils passent par la
dame des six
ça va être chaud à savoir à quel est le
roi qui va se faire toucher en premier
je trouve les bons là assez bon sur
cette séquence de
coût mais il faut qu'il soit un peu plus
rapide aux dames prend des quatre et ils
menacent mat
ils menacent toujours matt mais à
regarder miev qui coule à dalkia
repartiront f7 il va repartir vers gysi
cgr je pense menace dan behrman f5 et
d'alger 1 où il sort avec tours j'ai 3
il va y avoir un échec deux échecs au
leroy qui part en bep cap dam des deux
dames c3 d'emprunt f4 leroy qui monte et
les noirs qui vont devoir protéger dans
bay 4 échecs
puis on prend il va mettre la tour en un
an il va mettre la tour maintenant ou
pas il remet la dame en f4
c'est chaud il n'y a pas de prise en g7
je vois pas où est le mal
après tout ranger cette tour ses huit
tours ici aux essais les bonnes qui
tombe mais je sais pas ce qu'il a voulu
faire
il y avait tour ses huit pour g8 dames
c'est 3 à y avait ma temps de incroyable
incroyable il y avait maintenant 3 il a
pas eu le temps de le faire
il y avait tous ces huit dames c3 les
mecs
j'avais raté la dame c3 de base et il y
avait le mat mais il n'a pas eu le temps
de jouer ça fait la différence quand
même ça fait la différence à ce genre de
petits détails
ouais ça passe de deux plus deux heures
à +1 là en faisant ça c'est un détail
mais c'est pas un détail les mecs c'est
pas un détail
enfin la partie qui était serrée après
ça pouvait tourner d'un côté ou de
l'autre artemiev qui avaient bien
défendu
c'est peut-être sur le foot les quatre
échecs raté que le joueur arméniens
avaient laissé filer sa chance en tout
cas ça fait égalité 5 ennemis cinq et
demi et je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais d'après moi c'est plutôt le
joueur sibérien qui a le dessus
il est meilleur dans le petit jeu
tactique et il m'a l'air d'être en train
d'avoir failli mais il lui j'ai
l'impression qu'il a pris la mesure de
ce
adversaire et qu'il est en train de
petit à petit refermer son étreinte
peut-être qu'à rallier des cinq ici
surtout insiste adam repartira
éventuellement en b2 avec des idées de
cavale et c'est cette chatte que c'est
fini pour l'arménien il est bon pour la
retraite
d'après cyril 85 74 qui a quand même un
avis assez quand même important est la
champagne c'est cool pour le spectacle
françois da kid il fatigue heroes et
demi qu'il a que trente sept ans donc
heroes est en mode
ouais moi moi j'ai la quarantaine passée
37 ans est jeune il vous n en position
latérale de zouk gangs dans le tchat
alors est ce qu'un coup comme eux quatre
ici est jouable 1 pour aller menacer e5
tout bêtement rosen qui à 23 ans mais
qui a envie de se dire j'ai encore de
longues années devant moi à est
clairement le 4 par enfant
105 73 ans dans mon boulot ni françois
jacq attend boulot tout bleu ses 25 ans
les gens vieillissent vite quand ils
traînent autour des centrales nucléaires
d'edf
ou plutôt angie donc il fait de la peine
les ventes sont qui n'est pas bien am
c'est sûr ça fait mal ça fait mal mais
bon c'est la vie hein
que voulez vous c'est comme ça on n'y
peut rien la fff 5
mais bon sur 24
f café aux cinq quelque chose comme ça
mais madame en a trois il touche les
deux pions ouais il est mieux là
artemiev il faut il faut qu'il faut
prendre les points là pour artemiev il
prend à 5 protège des deux c'est dur
pour les voies d'un pour y arriver à
même de gagner c'est bien lui qui a
gagné le grande chaise tour là en inde
j'ai pas trop suivi et lucas et gagner
puis j'ai déjà oublié
vous allez me dire si je me trompe ouais
cellulaire c'est sur ce que le manuscrit
pour un mauvais mentale non non mais
plutôt un bon mental leeuwen
je suis à la question et toi en inde at
il déjà été dit il déjà des fils wayne
il est fini par 20 c en roumanie où est
peut-être paris dauphine et aussi du
coup c'est celui d'un alors qu'il va
venir mais j'ai envie de vous dire avec
avec tous les tous les gp fidh et tout
l'enjeu autour de la qualification à de
maxime aux candidats
[Musique]
les autres tournois là les grandes
chaînes tour semble bien fade
les autres charges et le chat de youtube
parce qu'on peut maintenant streamés sur
youtube et et twitch même s'il n'ya pas
pénalement de monde sur youtube par
amanda en tout le monde est au début les
personnes sur twitter ans à être
l'inversé aux dames c3 c'est bien joué
après je sais pas c'est la sienne
duchess comme donc c'est plus compliqué
pour moi à dire combien de gens
reçoivent les notifications c'est
toujours le même problème
place à un pion de plus il va falloir
convertir jouer et sur le roi faible
d'un côté et sur les pions passait de
l'autre
j'en profite et prendre une petite
respiration parce que ma voix le tas ne
tient plus le tan de la voix ne tient
plus
damages ci soit ça semble faire mal
damages c36 dame prend aussi soin et moi
ça d'un projet si ça ça ça va pas durer
très longtemps devrait jouer un peu plus
vite d'ailleurs je pense qu'on aurait dû
simplifier la vie mais briefé tour 4 en
pré refaire damage cette tour eu quatre
jeux pas trop l'intérêt de parents fait
échec quand h7
et bien elle ce sera le 19 du co les
vans peut-être tenté un dame c5 un truc
comme ça
non c'est sur youtube ou ici mais j'ai
juste l'impression que la plupart des
gens maintenant savent que les matches
sont sûres sont sur twitter
donc il ya moins de moins de gens qui
repasse via youtube voilà récupérer le
pion à il faut qu'ils réussissent à
trouver le bon set pour pas se prendre
un échec
il met la dame en f4 il va tenir
tranquillement dam des quatre échecs
alors où est ce qu'on cache le roi etc
les blancs
il faut jusqu'à chez leroy trouvait la
géométrie et c'est gagné
alors le roi qui va se cacher il veut
surtout pas échanger les dames bien sûr
avec les noirs alors y'a pas leur
ajoutant à 6,6 alors il ya de la casse
déchets qui s'y tenir ce n'est pas si
serein ça et continuer à échanger
il va mettre le pion h5 j'imagine en b4
bien jouer il va faire d'un me quatre
échecs mais roy ici d'un f4 dame g73jh
deux endroits je frappe avant d'amener
de l'échec s'il défend bien et elle est
bonne il faut quand même le souligner
soit plus d'une personne qui aurait
perdu en quelques coups et les bonnes
qui a résisté mais il perd le pion à son
adversaire qui va aller s'en prendre aux
matériels de l'autre côté
j'enrage 6 pas d'échec et c'est gagné et
pour la première fois du match
c'est artemiev qui prend les devants
ouais c'est bien joué
avec la mixeur aussi la relève de twitch
attention et je vais devoir ouvrir un
compte sur mixeur et j'agirai j'arrive
même pas ouvrir un compte en fait parce
que j'avais un compte
j'avais un vieux compte hotmail qui a
été désactivé et du coup il met en y
mettant pls c'est un peu spécial j'ai
l'impression mixeur mais je pense que ça
a donné un truc c'est comme ces
microsoft ça quand même donne
l'impression que ça n'a pas marché mais
bon non mais j'ai les deux chat ouvert
sur le même truc alpha choc là donc
c'est pas à ce pas un souci ouais
peut-être un jour ils achèteront
bitstream un jeu leur faire un deal à
100 millions pour six ans de stream
aussi bas et mais bon ce serait beau
quoi pourrait tellement stream et toute
la journée ce serait magnifique
les vans physique c'est l'arrêt sway non
c'est clairement du 1 et salut à l'ombre
de kef dans le tchat
une supportrice ce soir écoute je
supporte un beau match c'est une belle
compétition on se fait plaisir en
suivant en suivant un match de qualité
un pour le moment il ya eu des belles
parties
franchement un match un match agréable à
suivre tout cas on se fait on se fait
vraiment plaisir qu étudiant e 5 vient
chercher un peu de boulot ce cavalier
partir peut-être un jour vers f3
n'oubliez pas que le cavalier cloud est
un
si on joue par exemple dame j'ai cinq
cavaliers f3 et on peut dire adieu à la
partie il fait 4 ils le chassent sur
dame prend dédiant à jouer roi prend des
deux pour passer c'est prendre la
fourchette mais il y aurait eu cavaliers
ces cas c'était un point d'apprendre
d'eux ici sur carré sur la qualification
roi dame prend kf3 ça échange mais
c'était pas terrible il a fait table ses
trois tours d un écart et les c4
maintenant où c'est malin ça
dams et 5 contres clouage est-ce que
c'était si malin que ça de la part d'
artemiev ce qu'il est contre cloud et
maintenant dame c4 est quand même une
grosse menace
et le roi blanc est bien mal ouais mais
les pions français 4 il va vouloir
prendre le cadre est bonne à ces dames
trois dames ici ou là c'est une position
très compliqué ils menacent peut-être
qu'il y prend un cadre d'ailleurs le roi
qui s'en va et maintenant ils puisque ça
marche cavaliers prend sa cavale et
prend prise cavaliers prendre wabush
cavaliers prendre ton prend marche pas
et donc il a fait cavaler b2c joly sur
dame français trois cavaliers prend d 1
du coût d'un prend 1,7 et prend d un roi
eux deux
waouh il menace damas huit d'un cran à a
suite d'un côté et de l'autre côté avec
validé en l'air - de façon il allait
prendre la tour il obligé non 3d cette
dame 5 mai van damme prend des 3es à huy
pouvait pas prendre façon iv terme prend
des trois dames prend des deux matches
pardon sa santé que le roi blanc était
mal mais j'avais pas imaginer ce point
là donc là peut-être cassé trois pour
faire blackburn dame prend des deux
vraies c'est sa nature pas de maths
menace ici je serai bien qu'ils aient
prend le 4 mai place d'ahmed de maths
est sûre tu en prends tour d'air à moins
ce que je rate quelque chose qui prend 4
gagne sûr qu'il prendra même deux jeux
mes lordi way they prend 1,15 point 4
c'est fini
il a fait tout reprend d'âme des uns il
va faire cavalier f4 3g deux tours g8 le
roi tiers monde dames 1
c'est compliqué là bien il avait le gain
facile
il avait le gain facile et il s'est
compliqué la vie mais ça devrait passer
quand même
c'est fini et ça fait plus deux belles
fait ça fait mal hein ça fait mal les
bonnes qui a pas qu'à pas réussi à à
supporter psychologiquement la défaite
dans la partie pas la partie précédent
de la partie juste avant il n'a pas
réussi à accepter cette défaite et du
coup ça le fait un petit peu coulé un
petit peu beaucoup même et la main avec
deux points de retard
ça semble ça semble difficile voire même
impossible
impossible c'est pas dit mais vu qu'il
est sensiblement moins forts en bulles
est il faudra un bel exploit du joueur
arménien pour pour revenir dans la
course et il faut petit roeulx qui
recolle dès maintenant il reste trente
minutes dans les trois plus un ça veut
dire ça veut dire combien de partis cinq
parties en gros ouais il faut il faut il
faut qui recolle dès maintenant si leur
père une ouais ça va ça va commencer à
être dur allait il a les noirs le cavaly
qui est venu un peu denses et qui sera
approche deux des six partis hier quand
même très talentueux on voit son niveau
de jeu c'est impressionnant mais il
semble mécontent de ce cavalier à ces
quatre alors ils s'en débarrassent damas
quatre émanant sur b5 et prend b5
ouais c'est de nouveau une gaffe de
l'even en réalité un mais oui prisé dame
prend 1,8 à laon dame prend baisser avec
un produit peut-être caveirac et la dame
faut être enfermé oui dame prend b5 peut
être plus précis même produit qui est
peut-être plus trop de casse de sortie
mais probablement plus simple juste
d'encaisser le pion puis le cavalier
puis de rock et de jouer simplement les
deux pions plus en ayant enlevé à toutes
les ressources tactique de la position
sans l'être cadre aqmi dit levon levon
voulez-vous notre nos verres à la
remontée du sibérien c'est vrai que le
joueur sibérien il et il est bien bien
bien devant ils s'envolent
un ange sibérien s'est envolé joueurs
sibérien qui est en train de faire
l'écart les bonnes qui qui craque dans
la tête à l'ailé vont vous faire dame 17
en france et 4 x 6
allez un petit peu de faut mettre un peu
le feu dans cette position la dame
blanche qui va venir en c5
bombay non c'est 5 sûrement et matelas
tours en c1
peut-être même roi des deux tours d un
moment donné roi dame sait si ceci
possible pour que la finale est
maintenant droit des deux des trois
tours c'est un courant roc bien joué
tour des 3
il veut montant b caf avec le roi ou
voix a laissé bien les vans a voulu
mettre un peu de baume au coeur de
revenir un petit peu là dans la partie
il va récupérer un pion il va falloir
serrer les dents et chercher le nul à
l'essai relais dans ses relais dans les
bonnes serre les dents
c'est bientôt fini le match d'affaires
tour ces deux tours c'est un tout c'est
de tourner et de bien jouer belle
géométrie et surtout prend f3 à tour
prend d ici ce fou pranger de pas le
temps y est on comptait 8 sur échec qui
plus est et surtout reprend des deux qui
avale et prend des deux coupes rangée de
il y aurait une tour géante ou reprend
g7 et donc on va jouer cette finale
heleven qui va essayer de rentrer
peut-être après tour c'est un tour des
deux tours ces deux tours d un tour et
aller prendre le pion là bas c'est pour
ça qui vient à eux deux tours c'est six
tours ici tourisme sitour ici tour ici
il va quand même aller se faire taquiner
y est le pion là bas c'est bien jouer
les bonnes aller ça part de là pour pour
l'arménien sa part de la partie la
position était était difficile et la
petit à petit il se remet dedans c'est
la première fois que vous êtes ici
n'hésitez pas à nous mettre un petit un
petit follow un petit pouce bleu un
petit abonnement
ça fait toujours plaisir plus on est
joueur d'échecs plus à deux partis
rivaux ses parents peut-être quatre ici
pour couper et surtout rachat peut-être
tour d un pour couper mais est ce que
cette finale non elle a aucun intérêt
les noirs ont un pion h qui est vraiment
pénible
et si secret de pions passé ce sera fini
ah ça sent mieux pour les noirs en
réalité le pion h est plus fort que le
pion à c'est vrai que s'il recueille
statu quo salut tout cas et bonsoir
interactif ou dans le tchat
ouais peut-être je suis pas con il doit
la jouer à tour b2 il doit aller
chercher là nul maintenant tour c2i s'il
n'y avait pas tour ces deux attendait et
patois ces deux ici juste était pas une
gaffe mes lordi bassiste et une grosse
gaffe pour ces deux incroyables il a
raté tour ces 2 bat maintenant il va
perdre bien fait pour lui bien fait ou
pas d'ailleurs c'est pas sûr qu'il va
perdre ça reste quand même un quatre
contre trois et les blancs sont solides
allez les bons choix il a cherché sa là
ça ça peut être un nouveau retournement
artemiev qui avaient un avantage quasi
décisif et ans lara temps ça pourrait
refaire tourner le match un peu en
faveur de les bons surtout s'il est bon
la gagne ils vont kiffer des petits
étirements échec 3 g53 f4 artemiev qui
craque
il va faire tout à une fuite encore
trois à six mais là le pion est pour le
moment le pion tombe pas aller les bons
faut le faire tomber
faut faire tomber tu as eu quatre allers
est ce que c'est possible
est ce que c'est possible il va prendre
angers 4 est allé pions les envois c'est
nul mais elle était mieux autant les
bons français bien joué il ramène le roi
pour pas se faire couper et c'est le
joueur français philidor qui avait
théorisé ces finales le droit va venir
de la tour ans à 3 aux deux tours h2
échec 3-3 et la tour va partir m les
échec par derrière vous allez le voir en
direct
allez tour ces trois ici on attend et
desclaux pions noirs avancent on pousse
vous voyez même des joueurs du niveau de
levon essaye de porter la confusion et
l'enfer tout ranger 3 et roy eu deux
airois prend aux trois parties à
rebondissements qui finalement se solde
par là nul plutôt à les deux hommes
peuvent être mécontent de la partie ou
content ça dépend si regarde le verre à
moitié plein ou à moitié vide
allez on est reparti pour une nouvelle
partie avec une petite karo kann le tan
tient le tannat tenu un finalement le
tannat même bien tenu pour pour les deux
joueurs damas cinq échecs on va glisser
le petit échec s'en prendre aux rois
aller le fou qui va partir vers fougue
et de peut-être cavaliers b4 attention
ou c'est pas un problème c'est un
problème d prend le cas sur tb 4 à quoi
est dû ce rock cavaliers français de et
un coup de cavaliers qui bouge et il y
aura probablement un problème sur le
cavalier oms et 2 à lille a repris en
quatre avec le pion
et il va pouvoir aller aller chercher de
rock tbk trop calé face on n'a pas trop
le choix
cavalier procès d'oj mayo alquier b3 qui
a l'air fort la dame pourra pas protéger
et cette fois ci c'est les vonn qui a
réussi l'ouverture
attention attention côté sibérien ils se
relâchent et le joueur arménien et là
tapi dans l'ombre il est tapi dans
l'ombre et il est bien prêt à en sortir
de ce tapis est d'aller chercher la
lumière
alors attention tout de même un là il ya
une menace ça m'a l'air d'être à 3 à
mesra menacerait pas le cavalier puisque
le plus haut est cloué bien peut-être
pas de menaces du coup parti vraiment
intéressante une nouvelle fois très
accroché entre les deux hommes fous
aussi ce risque et viscas qui vise c'est
le cavalier bien rangée 5 qu'à l'élysée
dormi se fout ici
je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas kg 50 qui arrive souvent
réussi ce par un peu triste
même très triste il a fait ces quatre
d'accord et peut-être tour un équidé
fouet fin à tout moment aussi qui peut
arriver un il ya des a3 qui peuvent
rodez car l épreuve 6 e 5 aussi peut
être un plan pour s'ouvrir le fou il ya
beaucoup de possibilités intéressantes
un fait à 3 et maintenant qui est promu
6 c'est aussi très bien c'est un petit
cahier b3 ici première visée ce mec là
même qui aime pas trop les cahiers en b3
ça peut permettre faire qui est b3 faut
bouger de cavale il pourra revenir en d2
attention quand même à ce fou qui peut
sauver aussi f4 pour faire 5 peut-être
f4 aussi un coup incarne f3 une idée
aussi très décente d'affaires à
reconstruire quand même la partie allait
la fée tour des huit cavaliers f6 c3
bien joué
roch carrier g5y fera cavalier e 5 pour
aller viser la case d3 et partent pour
cette dame en e1 d'avoir bougé il peut
pas la mettre
de fait c'est la tour qui doit aller ici
pour pouvoir éventuellement mettre le
fou en c4 peut-être dupouy passant h3 et
que vous ça c'est un très bon coup
fourrage 3 pas difficile mais pas si
simple genre de coups pas si évident que
ça à voir et il a vu fois je crois bien
joué trois fuites émanant maintenant
maintenant et maman et maman est pas si
facile leeuwen qui devrait un peu
accélérée là peut-être juste dames 3 du
couvent maintenant kg 5e lieux saints
cas il se lance là dedans
quatre quais des trois allers ouais
c'est bien joué quand même un du côté de
de l'even c'est vrai que c'est pas si
grave de perdre ce fou est désactivé le
cavalier parce qu'il va gagner une
qualité d'une manière x ou y
il faut qu'il y en ait si ce qui est des
huit tours des 8es ray mais ils
s'activent leeuwen qui est passé sur de
lui un il se remet mal autant dans une
partie qui semblait complètement
maîtrisé et à se prendre pour des huit
tempo et il va se faire danser le
cavalier vers h5 qui va menacer le pion
f4 à moins qu'ils viennent en d5 même
déjà python h5 un cavalier mevel de
l'autre côté mais il n'apparaît que ça
valait vonn qui contrôle toutes les
cases tour est fluide sur f5 yakaré
lycéens tension et le kg en f4 qui est
mal 27 secondes
ça pourrait mal tourner de nouveau ça
pourrait de nouveau mal tourner et f5 à
y penser à ça va être joué
on voit pas trop d'options au tour prend
c'est un va être jouée fou prend ses
seins il faut aller la rechercher la
caboche et cavaliers mevel dans du bon
côté de l'échiquier cette fois qui
défend un peu le roi la dengue qui va
venir en atx si ce qui va venir recouper
l'échiquier pour menacer la tour voilà
c'est chose faite
la dame qui a pu voir jaillir vers des
deux peut-être attention à ne pas se
pendre un fou prend h7 quand même qui
empêche les tours j'ai huit tours j'ai
huit échecs jouer l'euro sur oicha et
karine icher trois rois f2 et forcé
c'est le seul coup faut jouer les bonnes
il ya peut-être fou g4 aussi
ouais mais les vols là qui est en train
de se faire retourner h3 cavalli j'ai
trois oreilles c'est terminé h5
peut-être même intermédiaire 5 jouer
maintenant et les bonnes dames trois
tours f8 dame prend 1,5 sur échec
il s'est fait retourner tour f4
peut-être tombé huit très bien joué tour
b8 la belle symétrie
il va encore chauffer un pion et il va
forcer les changes des dames où elle
coûte cher c'est la halle est bonne
qu'at-il fait il était complètement
gagnant dominant il avait il avait tout
pour lui et art énième vraiment vraiment
impressionnant dans ce petit jeu
tactique il est vraiment très fort
le l'arménien le le russe pardon le
sibérien sa fille pas rien quand même
déjà ça j'ai envie de vous dire mais
c'est vrai qu'il est vraiment vraiment
impressionnant il réussit il réussi des
miracles est difficile pour les 22 de
revenir vraiment il faudra faire des
efforts titanesques pour pouvoir
égaliser on dit dans le chat il ne
s'appelle pas blake pour rien et la paix
damas quatre tours b 5 peut être une
idée damas quatre pour aller peut-être
chercher un tempo là est tombé 5 pour
aller en chercher ici murray cavaliers
cinq salles ira quand même pour les
noirs dans cette anglaise bien citer
règles pour les commentaires mais qu'est
ce que on te voit rarement sur tweets
chaudeyrac tayrac on voit que sur
youtube il fait f3 ouais donc ils
contrôlent un peu le cavalier et en cas
de prise prise il pourra peut-être jouer
un jour avec 4 pour s'ouvrir le fou j'ai
l'impression que le match est en train
d'être un peu à sens unique non mcf 4-1
puis si je pense pas que je jouerais
mais je me poserai la question peut-être
que c'est débile 1 il après will var du
tour f5 aussi qui va rôder
alors il est bien à la rareté miew c'est
cruel un pur pour l'arménien mais il est
juste moins forte mais fine à calage
d'ailleurs lâche calage start et nief 21
ans est impressionnant comme il
m'impressionne plus que dunga après il
est un peu dans le dur depuis quelques
mois
bref deux tours f1 qui arrive
il reste la tour en f1 ça à peu près sûr
prend des 600 première oui puisqu'il ya
le fou j'ai dans l'air et surtout
pranger deux français- 7
c'est peut-être une gaffe cependant il
faut prendre cette pardon là j'ai eu un
petit coup du moi aussi me suis bien
défoncé les cordes vocales depuis depuis
2h30 de commentaires là j'ai besoin de
souffler je suis comme les joueurs g20
de un petit temps mort là un petit à
petit récupération la voix ne tient plus
voit pas beaucoup sur le circuit n'a pas
beaucoup d'invitations et bonsoir à
edward dans le tchat
mais le tan aussi ré le tad aussi pas
mais c'est dur pour la voir je gagne
bien je me fais plaisir mantes le pion à
fsa était en l'air pour qu'il récupère
tamack 4 et dame prend à celle ci est
toujours allé regarder les pions comme
ça c'est un peu comme au billard mais
celui-là il m'a l'air d'être un peu
empoisonné
parce que le cahier viendront c5 et la
dame aura du mal à revenir en jeu
kamali f5
ce que ton prend 1,2 et jouable c'est la
question pour le moment je lui raté un
truc là je suis un peu dans le dur
j'ai quand même regardé qu'est ce qui se
passe ça ça m'intéresse ça m'intrigue
mama 4 maintenant oui c'était pas si
simple en fait il voulait jouer sur les
problèmes multiples il joue très bien
restivo la wayne en platt qui a réussi
une belle performance à ce soir
mongai qui défend tous mais les blancs
qui ont du mal à progresser
il reste combien de temps à jouer dans
cette cadence iris 9 minutes
ça peut être dans son intérêt même s'il
peut pas vraiment le faire dans cette
position mais jouer que deux parties
artemiev dans la cadence mais
normalement il y en aura encore trois
puisque les parties durent cette fille
minutes avec celle là dure encore un peu
plus d'une minute fois que c'est
possible 1 40 secondes de chaque côté et
de nouveau une position assez bordélique
bien sûrement rentrer dans la vie
n'allait faire nul je pense artemiev
tour eiffe sept tours à quatre tiroirs
tour f2 pour défendre et puis tour c'est
cette maintenant et tour est fluide
j'imagine mais toi fils tête retour b2
avec l'idée surtout rêve cette tourbe et
8 échecs et ouais autour des 2 et
surtout receipts tour échec a ouai mais
touré cheick 3 monte mais tu rêves
septembre en c5
c'est ça le truc il ya ces cinq qui
resté en l'air attention les bonnes il
s'est remis mal les bonnes
il s'est remis mal à ces la catastrophe
à là pour les bonnes les manants tour
des 17 qui va monter mon asthme at il va
se prendre un échec deux échecs trois
échecs il va perdre le pion à 7 qui re
menacera maths il va reprendre un échec
dans la face et il va se faire prendre
sa tour b6 rohm and haas matt tour c'est
cet hiver e menacés maths et on est
reparti comme en 40
trouver cinq tours prend ses trois tours
france et 5 et il a trois pions noirs
il se fait changer les tours
georges et cinq échecs maintenant qu'ils
gagnent carrément la tour et ça fait
plus 4 ouais non les bonnes la quille
les bonnes qui je pense qu'on peut le
dire est au fond un les bonnes et au
fond là ouais donc là on voit la
variante que mathieu tombe à dieu quand
êtes vous a parlé avant-hier sur la
chaîne youtube
il nous a exactement parler de cette
variante là contre la carro cannes donc
voila comme da premier sur l'info
premier sur les variantes toujours
au-dessus téléphone mais là quatre
points d'écart
il peut remonter au mieux s'ils gagnent
vite à plus de avant les bullet ce qui
semble être un être un déficit même à
plus de il serait pas à moins de il
serait très mal mais mais mais ce serait
un rêve pour lui déjà d'être d'être d'en
être là d'en arriver là mais il est fait
le plus probable qui tourna - entre -3
et -5 et ce que j'ai vu le montage de
ludwig ouais j'ai vu le montage de
ludwig qui a bossé avec avec le
précepteur exactement rêve j'ai vu ce
montage j'ai vu ce montage démontage on
l'y a le secret ai-je envie de dire
alors dans cette finale est un peu un
peu bizarre cette finale pions noirs qui
ont beaucoup avancé de partout mais
c'est peut être difficile ça a laissé
beaucoup d'espacés blancs ça a laissé
beaucoup de cazaux blanc mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il en a trop laissé que
il a il a trop laissé les blancs avancé
le roi peu plus rock n' ya pas de grands
servait un grand roque ça irait
complètement en fait mais j'ai
l'impression que les blancs ont laissé
les noirs s'installer trop
confortablement sur l'échiquier x alex
ça va être du coup très difficile de
finir le développement mais bon y à 0,4
à la casse c4 il ya des cases pour les
bonnes et il compte bien il compte bien
rentrer dans les trous les bonnes en
tout cas il ya deux beaux trous là en c4
et f4 pour les cavaliers
il ya de quoi se faire plaisir pour les
blancs avoir réussi car au lieu de les
relier pareil part vers des 4l étonnant
qu'un milieu d'eux et peut-être même sur
cavaliers c4 mais il semble quand même
reculer partout
pas si évident à jouer avec les noirs
packham envie d'envoyer 4 3 un moment
donné ou c5 d'abord pour éviter qu'il y
ait des quatre mètres de fond bessette
et envoyé d'être une menace qui
m'échappe ou quelque chose vous est
absente et c'est la dégringolade arrêt
exactement ça va regarder dégringole
pardon de partout alors fou c'est 5
il va ya voir f 4k et g4 aussi qui va
rôder même f4 fou prend à f2 voilà les
bonnes l'impression qu'il a fait
n'importe quoi
c'est triste mais il craque
il craque dans la tête
le slip ne tient plus pour les bonnes il
faudrait pas quand même ça tourne à la
correctionnelle mais là c'est vraiment
une
une leçon qu'il est en train de recevoir
ses rangs une leçon peut-être h3 ouais
mais bon qu'est issermann en f4 nom qui
va arriver
n'oublions pas qui peut pas faire petit
requin je comprends pas trop g4 à la fin
je 3 ah oui le fou est enfermé au passé
c'est encore un autre problème mais là
ça c'est une partie vraiment raté la
part de l'even qui semble semble
vraiment dans le dur qui semble un peu
avoir lâché 1
il semble un petit peu avoir lâché et
maintenant ça va être compliqué de
rester dans le match
le roi qui montant des six cavaliers qui
est menacée faire tout reprend c4 a
minima bref s'ils seront assez 7
c'est une option
on va voir si c'est celle qui choisit
elle a fait qu'un vieux quatre fous ab3
fou j'ai 4 3 alors là est ce qu'il ya
des gains directs reprend des trois et
on prend des trois donc non il place sa
tour sur la colonne eu 50 secondes
normale en ce sera la dernière partie de
la cadence
on n'a pas le timer officielle à
quelques secondes près mais j'imagine je
vais avoir du mal à tourner à mieux que
que plus beaucoup et il a récupéré deux
pions et artemiev qui a réussi pas
encore à un conclure me prépare
peut-être kg 5 et prend le 6e tour f6
menace le cavalier sans visa et réussit
pas à conclure artemiev pour le moment
on jan qui a mis une belle défense en
place et qui résiste vraiment bien au vu
de la position affreuse qu'il a à
défendre celle qui réussit pas à trouver
le comment faire sauter le verrou il va
peut-être prendre là nul
bon un petit peu regrettable pour
artemiev mais vont ils à 4 points
d'avance les douanes qui disparaît petit
à petit de la caméra ces quatre points
d'avancé il veut pas ne veut pas prendre
de risque qui gère son match et il
tourne et tourne à plus 4 artemiev ça
peut se comprendre
alors on va bientôt passer à la à la
pause voyez les commentateurs anglais
robert s
et ariane paris dont qui commentent qui
commente le match et nous on va faire
une petite pause et on revient d'ici six
minutes a tout de suite les mecs
[Musique]
alors les amis on est reparti oriane
paris qui commentent en anglais qui en
bas dans son club d'échecs il sut
complètement ensemble qui sut alors
laissé par part si l'on me justine henin
et maria de paris mettant sur mvl en
sueur on sent une belle en sueur sur la
photo on va laisser les pubs repartir
vous nous demande dans le chat c'est
quoi le score c'est +4 pour artemiev
avant les plus est donc ça semble
compliqué de chez compliqué on verra les
du coup d'arrêt qui est là cette fois ci
qui dit des choses on ne sait pas
lesquelles on voit son twitter pourquoi
pas j'ai envie de dire et il dit des
trucs
il ne s'est pas mon avis ne sais pas bon
alors nous reste une belle demeure de
match à suivre
on a commencé le match à 18 heures donc
les joueurs sont forcément un petit peu
fatigué mais vont ils vont revenir en
pleine forme
la france toujours mené 1 à 0 contre la
moldavie d'ailleurs qu'est ce que c'est
que ça alors elle va se montrer très
bout du monde rahim grand prix et
premiers non qualifiés au vélo et la
wild card en russe je sens bien mais
c'est possible
ah c'est reparti c'est reparti avec donc
s'il veut aller fente vladislav artemiev
avec les pièces blanches face à levon
aronian avec les pièces noires et il va
absolument falloir pour aronian faire un
gros début de bullet s'il souhaite avoir
encore une chance de l'emporter dans ce
match et rester en vie dans la
compétition on sait que normalement le
bullet c'est son talon d'achille mais
est-ce que achille va être va être plus
fort finalement malgré le talon le talon
que peut-être son adversaire ne va
jamais découvrir donc il met le fou ou 3
il va reprendre de f j'imagine dont il
reprend de la dame
arte mais ce qui va mettre qui va les
mettre un cavalier en d5 un cavalier en
afc qui veut jouer pour pour ces cases
mais les bonnes qui mène une première
escarmouche avec avec saddam son
cavalier il va falloir qu'ils jouent
offensivement et qui se réveille
tactiquement il peut le faire les bonnes
c'est un des meilleurs joueurs du monde
il peut il peut remonter un écart de
quatre points
on voit où est l'eau avec une centaine
de points et l'autre différence dans la
cadence donc tout est possible il avait
été comme je le disais
copieusement dominés par ci ont déjà
méfier ruzza en bullet c'est peut-être
le numéro 1-2 mondiale en tout cas c'est
le grand espoir mondial du bullet et
donc y avait pas de honte à se faire
marcher dessus
surtout que finalement il avait réussi à
serrer à serrer les fesses j'ai envie de
dire et à remporter le match
pour le moment la position semble
correct pour les deux joueurs le cavaly
re5 de l'even est très bien placé ou la
dame qui partiront à 7
alors ça on l'avait pas vu venir il est
parti avec la dame en a 7 pour les
ramasser les pions alors est-ce que les
vannes va jouer tourbe et 8 pour les
défendent oui c'est ce qui vient d'être
fait d'ahmed de leur tour vers une case
plus central et c'est ça qui ferment les
portes il ferme les écoutilles
alors la tour qu'il est en d1 on va
jouer peut-être pour la case des 5s que
cavalier va jaillir fou prend en tout
reprend c'est possible oui mais la tour
en f1 il veut bien bloqué à la poussée
du pion est froid h 2 il se replace à la
petite parents agissent peut-être une
tour qui va venir sur la case m6 on ne
s'est pas à la dame qui vit à angers 3
qui vient prendre la priorité sens
interdit pour la dame nord elle peut pas
revenir g5 qui a joué tout bref si c'est
intéressant bullet on sait que la dame
peut être bien plus forte que les tours
parce que c'est difficile de voir les
double attaque et c'est pour ça qu'il a
décidé d'échanger lecavalier st qui
disparaît le pion qui poussent en effet
5 ça continue à échanger et les noirs
semblent mieux aller faut faire
attention à ce qu'ils ont 17 faut pas
laisser tomber des cinq allers leeuwen
22 secondes contre 24 pour le moment ça
va des 4 et la sai et sa part 2 partout
en échec qui arrive au f5 dame prend des
quatre tours f5
il défend qu'avait lieu de peut-être
n'en dame prend des quatre joueuses
jouent le clouage maintenant le roi de
l'even qui est ouvert j'ai peur que vu
la cadence la dame ne soit bien plus
forte que les tours c5 bien joué il veut
préparer du cavalier e 4 adaptive
arrivant aux cinq as d'avancé ceinture à
tour 17 encore qui sauve tout pour le
moment
le joueur arménien tient et artemiev qui
la joue un peu pleutre et qui prend là
nul il va pas falloir payer c'est nul
offerte aux joueurs arménien alors
prochaine partie maintenant les bonnes à
les blancs et ils jouent
ils jouent ces trois au deuxième
attention paquet et provoqua trevi
damman parce que les dames cap dans ma
cave des chèques
maintenant le fou qui part en b 5 sur
échec et la tour qui va venir en a alors
le cash qui me demande un pronostic je
donnerais bien semer un temps nuire
grand avantage ici aux joueurs sibérien
qui qui plus est est plus fort et qui a
quatre points d'avancé au classement
alors il a fait qu'ils avaient trois
dames ces deux on va avoir ce qui
réussit à faire les bonnes j'ai
l'impression qu'il a il n'a pas réussi à
obtenir ce qu'ils souhaitaient dans
l'ouverture et épaississe
et peut-être et peut-être prise et tour
ses sept tours c'est 8 mai cavagnan à 5
y sera bien placé on peut s'en
débarrasser après tour c7 et cavaliers
c4 éventuellement en deux temps m la
tour ans et 8
alors il a fait b3 pour pour stopper les
karellis et 4 on pourra juste faire
cavaler 17 avec les noirs puis b6 des 5
peut être aussi d'alternative sur 5 pour
avoir cavalier e 4 ça peut être un coup
à cette thématique genre b6 ici
cavaliers ces quatre des cinq qui
comprend cavaliers prend il commence par
des services sur cinq il peut y avoir
aussi des bêtises qui rôde un fouet f4
intermédiaire la tour qui va partir vers
ces deux mais cavaliers ps est et il a
peut-être raté fouet f4 il a voulu jouer
au malin
alors qu'est ce qui se passe sur b6 fou
prend ses sept tours prend ses 7es
lecavalier à cinq a plus de gaz
et ouais et s'est jouée par parts et
nief à il a peut-être raté ça le joueur
arménien ils ont tous les deux voulu
jouer au malin et on va voir on va on
verra bien qui rira le dernier
allez faut prendre rendez 5 et prendre
un set et après cavale et prend des cinq
faire un petit échec en 1 8
alors il va couvrir avec le fou il va se
donner la case g7 pour le roi et il va
aller chercher maintenant du jeu allèles
dames poule b katika d'un petit tempo
sur la tour la tour qui bouge en deux
car ali hafsi cela il tient tout le
cavalier en d5 qui se fait chasser tour
c'est un roi j'ai deux tours il va y
avoir tout reprend des cinq des échanges
massif tout reprend à deux et ça risque
se diriger on sait pas parce qu'un
cavalier e 5 et ça se dirige vers
quelque chose de très compliqué la tour
qui va les prendre en b3 et les blancs
qui vont avoir un pion plus mais un pion
à difficile à gérer face au duo tour
cavaliers alors le cavalier qui passe on
sait si si vous menacez qu'il prend à 5
il va pouvoir réaliser qu'elle prend à 5
ans il prend l'option roi des saints qui
va sûrement y avoir que les prends b4
prises et ça va jouer ça va jouer à la
dure avec les pions passer d'un côté et
une tour qui va pouvoir venir se
sacrifier sur l'option b au cas où
j'imagine que les blancs sont bien ici
même très bien on va aller raser le pion
g6
il va falloir revenir pour pouvoir se
sacrifier alors peut-être par tout aussi
ce tour à tour b 1 et tours prend b2 ça
va être un petit peu laborieux mais la
voilà roi je crois qu'il va partir
j'ai quatre tours prend b2 h5 on va
envoyer le contre je il peut même faire
tout un peut-être tout elle fait un tour
des cinq peut-être maintenant et
peut-être tour des saints qui est
intéressant surtout en f1 je sais pas si
tour d un été en pêchable en tout cas ça
pas été joué les pions parts mais le roi
a eu revient à ça va ça va pas être allé
assez vite pour pour les bonnes tour b3
maintenant peut-être pour tout couper ou
pas ou pas il fait tomber cette et
touriste il veut jouer le zouk gang
alors est ce qu'on peut faire trois
points f4 h 6 3 et 5 h 7 et les pions
pas qui va repasser le roi et maître la
tour derrière alors la tour pourquoi il
ne mettait pas sur la troisième ici il a
mais en f1 3,5 ya pas j'essaye at-on g1
et là il ya tout reprend f4 et tout
rejet car à toi exactement très bien
joué les pions qui peuvent pas avancer
et ça fait maintenant plus 5 attention
les bonnes les vonn qui est en train de
couler il reste 22 minutes de jeu 5
points d'écart
allez bonne qui va passer à la trappe
les a mis là à mon avis
c'est plus ou moins chose faite un + 5
il ya déjà huit minutes de passer
artemiev qu'il est ce qu'il est c'est
goûter le temps hebdo qui se demande
comment il a perdu sa valise la tour f 1
c'était pas terrible
il fallait monter droit plus vite il a
fait g4 h4 fallait monter droit avec les
pions pour au moins faire nul mais les
vols là qui est en train de couler quel
point les cinq points d'écart 22 minutes
à jouer
il reste il reste quoi il reste cette
partie si cette partie ça me paraît très
compromis attention de pas faire le
petit rock ici parce que rafa prend info
pro f si ces cavaliers 17 avec une
fourchette qui gagnerait la qualité est
une nouvelle fois les vannes qui est mal
autant et qui a du mal à résister à la
vitesse du joueur arménien à la dame
tuant b4 d'amd 5,6 et ses 3,4 alors est
ce qui peut prendre en c6 intermédiaire
mais de façon quand il prend 1,7 ce sera
la dame qui reprendra et c'est vrai que
ce cas maintenant le cap va être bien
placé joueurs sibérien qui est bien dans
la vente on verra en 2001 ce qui donne
il jouera contre le vainqueur du match
ouais c'est so mvl ça va être dur à
encaisser 5 qui a décidé de filer un
pion pour pas laisser le cavalier en
quatre c'est loin d'être idiot ce
cavalier était vraiment un empêcheur de
tourner en rond
alors il peut avoir une idée c'est sur
wave sept tours 1 dames tour des vins
peut-être et sur dame des six cavaliers
5 donc oui mais la dame ici il va
sûrement faire bref cette idée car
peut-être mais il va sans prendre
vraiment options aussi slevan une
nouvelle fois mal autant et là il a plus
le droit à l'erreur ainsi père surtout
que c'est des parties longues à chaque
fois je vois qu'il prenne vraiment le
temps il prospère le pion v6 de toute
manière et ça va de nouveau être un bel
avantage pour pouvoir tenir
qui va pouvoir vis et le pion des cinq
heleven qui une nouvelle fois et mal
autant mal apposition mal partout mais
de dos et une sciatique
c'est à ticket chic est dans le dur
pour alain bago au choix est la tour qui
va peut-être venir en d1 va se passer
tour 3 to re 1 c'est bien joué
belle harmonie des pièces et non pas de
finale prévus pour pour la finale de
gris tout qu'on peut pas tout faire les
mecs c'est quand même compliqué dessus
tout les partis tous les tournois en
direct en différé
ces jolies dames des cinq cavaliers
prend et il va les jouer cette finale il
va faire monter droit il va faire monter
droit mais bon les noirs ou un roi un
peu plus actifs
peut-être peut la tenir à temps la
finale pas qu'elle prend des 5 à 5 à 6
et droit est trop loin jab sont rois ces
cinq à six prises prise 3 b 6 3 et 6 3
et il est juste en retard c'est le roi
blanc qui rendent bizarre ce choix
d'échangés russie c'est laurent blanc
qui rentrent en premier juste roi prend
un f5 îles féroé c'est trois g7 g3 ouais
c'est ça ouais il va il va tout prendre
et les bonnes qui perd et ça fait plus 6
bat autant dire que le match est plié
les amis ghana e-services finale il faut
la suivre
si tu nous fais un tu me fais un tipi de
500 600 euros je te la suite c'est une
finale
certes mais bon peut pas suivre tous les
tournois tous les matches et tout tout
tout c'est impossible
ça fait trop bien ces cas tu vas prendre
rang qui est des katja voir f5
maintenant qui va arriver tout allant de
choses comme ça les intéresse pas tu la
filiale great shook up to date d'arrêt
on suit nv est là on suit pas tous les
tournois sinon on n'y arriverait pas en
plus rassurés que d'une chaise comme
j'arrivais pas non plus ne serait pas
suffisant alors là les blancs doivent
être bien quand il va y avoir du cahier
des singles f5 qui rôdent à l'ailé bonne
il faut le faire mettre un peu de baume
au coeur à mais se prend au lard et il a
fait cinq mais pas dans le bon tempo
elle a été de 5 même maintenant pour
jouer sur ce courage
c'est horrible c'est au riz pour les
bonnes dames c4 ici
ces 8 kg arrive à tous qui arrive je
suis un peu d'éviter pour les vols mais
bon ils résistent paix prévue dans cette
partie quand même il a trouvé un peu de
jeu sibérien qui n'a peut-être pas la
gagner celle-là elle va tout prendre des
8 et prend 9 6 il a craqué dans celle là
finalement notre ami artemiev ça va
faire du bien allé vonn en retour des
cinq annonces ah non il n'ya pas qu'il
prend des cinq horloges
c'est fou ça il était cloué
c'est fou ça les amis il y arrive plus
on voit avec un peu de retard de la
guerre il en rigole mais avant il y
dirige onnaing y rit jaune
il est oublié que j'étais cloué est ce
qu'il ya des menaces de maths ou pas
semble pas mais il est quand même bien
autant les bonnes à l'épaule a gagné
celle là il faut la jouer à fond
on va à près de 60 sa laisse couler
tellement de temps cette partie je crois
que mathématiquement c'est quasi fini 1
de toute façon là s'ils gagnent pas plus
6 ce sera dur à remonter mais des échecs
de partout on essaye de se cacher il a
plutôt attention les bonnes il a plus de
temps ils trouvent pas le mat
le roi qui monte à lille a réussi à
gagner
fou la partie qui s'enflamme cavaliers
f5 d'un math 3
allez on va dire qu'il va réussir à
gagner celle-là les bonnes au prix d'un
effort titanesque
c'est pas évident 1 c'est pas évident
arrive à se prendre dame j'ai quatre
échecs
aïe aïe aïe alors elle était pas
gagnable de toute façon il s'est fait
changer les dames et en plus il a fait
traîner un temps fou donc l'aria plus si
c'est maintenant il reste plus que 13
minutes 30
l'art est tombé 5 il a raté quelque
chose quand même
ça va faire une petite finale insipide
[Musique]
mais bien entendu maintenant non gestion
côté à côté sibérien sept grands groupes
ranger cette frange et 7,8 grand roque
tension ne pas se prendre un problème
sur f2 food et 4 il revient il protège
tout est là toute façon il a juste
besoin de faire des parties qui dure il
a même plus besoin de de faire deux nuls
il peut tout perdre a maintenant le seul
truc dont il a besoin artemiev c'est de
faire jouer on va lire de trois minutes
par partie de jouer une partie une
finale comme ça qui dure je rappelle
qu'il ya c'est la cadence et une seule
une minute plus une seconde parcours
donc du moment que qu'on joue pas trop
mal et qu'on donne pas la partie on
arrive vite à on arrive vite à trois
minutes de jeu puisque en jouant 30
coups sarah va rajouter une minute des
trente coups là ils vont être ils vont
être atteints dans cette partie et même
plus qu'atteint et donc ça fera tourner
le chrono dans tous les cas et ce sera
ce sera un client au prochain tour
pour le vainqueur du match wesley so
maxime vachier lagrave qui aura lieu je
vous le rappelle le 19 ce sera un vrai
client
ce sera un vrai client artemiev à mon
humble avis ce sera l'inde est l'un des
favoris
c'est l'un des favoris de la compétition
de façon il en 2000 donc c'est un peu
une lapalissade mais mais bon il est
vraiment fort
alors là ils peuvent compter six prises
prise pas ça mais il peut faire fou
prendre prisa et fukuoka terrasse et 7
pour éviter les échecs gfu aux six
maintenant pas mettre laurent ces trois
mois ses six têtes un petit coup de
pouce et d'heures et petit coup de fouet
officie lui imaginer mais là la position
assez égal et vonn est ce qu'ils vont
faire perpète non parties qui dure comme
judée façon c'est dans l'intérêt de
joueurs sibérien d'avoir d'avoir des
partis qui durent longtemps
mais les bonnes qui va et qui essayent
de s'introduire qui essaye de faire des
choses c'est bien ce que fait les bonnes
tout cas il réussit à retourner un peu
la partie et là il ya des quatre échecs
qui semble fort qui lui aurait permis de
gagner du matériel et là il a juste
faire une tableau blanc lé vonn qui est
vraiment plus qui n'est vraiment plus
dedans c'est un énième cadeaux
malheureusement je vois un média qui
s'est un peu disloqué alors
qu'est-ce qui veut nous faire protège le
pion alors attendez là il va y avoir un
problème dam des cinq dames 6 dames g4
et ça va faire plus 7
le match est vraiment plié de chez plier
voit moins c'est clair c'est net c'est
précis sans bavure victoire facile
c'est la priorité de maxime en cette fin
d'année c'est ça c'est clairement pas le
cipi chess alors oui mais ça peut leur
mettre en confiance ça peut leur mettre
en confiance ça fait pas de mal de jouer
de jouer et de voir là pour reprendre un
peu la forme c'est un bon entraînement
wlan me disais que pour great choc
lorsqu'il y avait eu lorsque vlad le
second dès qu'ils avaient essayé
d'organiser les dates de ce pitch s de
demander dans le calendrier pour qu'elle
tombe avant avant des tournois
importants et savez ça avait plutôt bien
fonctionné mais elle m'avait dit de
faire les speechs juste avant il avait
fait la même chose avec katia l'agglo et
il m'avait dit que ça va aussi aussi pas
mal fonctionné que c'était existait bien
d'avoir un match d'entraînement comme ça
donc c'est pas forcément évidemment tu
le prends pas comme un truc primordial
mais c'est pas ça idiot de les jouer en
tout cas et 2 et de zones à fond comme
commun comme un gros match amical tu
vois comme un test match au rugby tu as
et amicale sans être amical quoi c'est
amical sur le papier puis une fois que
tu joues depuis une demi-heure t'as plus
envie de perdre donc c'est pas si voilà
c'est pas idiot de les jouer pour
surtout la vue vu la défaite difficile
qui qu'a connu maxime contre gries
tchouk c'est à mon avis pas pas une
mauvaise chose qu'il est qu'il est ce
match contre eux wesley histoire de tout
de suite se remettre dans le bain
non je pas discuté avec maxime après ça
j'ai pas trop envie de demander pas trop
dégouté je trouve dans ces cas là que tu
peux vous poser que des questions un peu
débile ouais ouais c'est qui me fait un
peu peur moi aussi après ouais c'est
bizarre il a super bien joué au
championnat du monde 960 il a très mal
joué au dernier grande chaise tour est
un peu étonnant et ce n'est sûrement
faire comprendre aux farc et prend 17
nuls mais peut-être gagner un petit peu
quand même peut-être un peu marre tout
cas ce sera un beau match
moi c'est une elfe ou de couleur opposée
elle doit être nul les nuls même salut
jutra ben
c'est un peu bizarre et dia maxime sera
pas trop déçu tu as inventé une qualif
aux candidats ça va c'est se passe bien
pour toi à devon aoki réussi quelque
chose n'a pas bien défendu et artemiev
par la partie qui va probablement soldé
par une victoire côté arménien il va
être le fourbe et 8
ouais mais ils rapportent ou défendre va
indéfiniment magouilles et les bonnes
qu'en même temps on verra le grand prix
tel aviv en tout cas ce sera sympa à
suivre compris jérusalem j'espère que
vous suivre en notre compagnie sur tu as
comme france vous avez l'habitude depuis
fait longtemps qu'on suit tous ses
matches ensemble
je pense que vous l'avez déjà mauvaise
presse et des beaux matches à chaque
fois
tu as fait de vlad contre sacha toorop
contre sacha faire contre gries tchouk
vaccinia même impatient d'y à toi ça va
être sympa et de façon même si maxime se
fait éliminer au premier tour on suivra
plus loin puisque de toute façon on aura
la problématique de la khalifa et bien
on était bien évidemment très content de
la qualification de gris tchouk pour la
finale ouais c'était sympa ligne avec
mathieu cornette il est vraiment bon
pour les analyse mathieu honnêtement
j'ai pas travailler la partie je me la
passe j'ai passé bizarre là comme parti
c'est bizarre en façon le match mais je
tiens à tour des cinq races et
d'ailleurs dur pour artemiev
ah non il est bon mathieu il est très
bon avants basques avec les meilleurs
est ce que réfute peut ne pas être
candidat ouais mais ça dépendra de la
finale s'ils gagnent la finale c'est sûr
si la gagne pas et encore une chance
qu'il y soit pas donc il va la gagner
encore les bonnes mais bon le match est
derrière
non mais bon il se reprend une tactique
à deux balles incroyables et vol
incroyable se prendre ça et qu une pièce
de plus il y ait vraiment plus un wes il
ya eu la finale c'est 100 % et surtout
si gagner avec le bonus crois que c'est
fini
et si la gagne pas ça dépendra des
tableaux des machins on discutera plus
tard
mais blake doit être content la faille
des comptes en la poésie avec le bonus
c'est fini et presque 1 il y est presque
il y est prescrite chioukhs et les vins
n'y sera pas comme ça c'est dit et
artemiev non plus puisqu'il n'est pas
éligible à la wild card qui pourra pas
il pourra pas être pris lui non plus
pour les candidats donc là on a affaire
à deux joueurs qui seront pas wesley so
qui est encore dans le pitch s n'y sera
pas non plus duda n'y sera pas en gros
beaucoup de monde n'y seront pas et ici
rate la qualif great flu que devra jouer
un bon match de barrage contre les
autres russes eddie gill à la wild card
non je n'ai pas de problème elior pour
la 1ère francophones en fait je ne suis
pas encore esclaves duchess com
donc quand je stream déjà entre 30 et 40
heures dans la semaine
l'échauffement importantes comme l'arena
francophone chez le droit de pas faire
ça va je peux souffler soit il encore
une petite chambre m est microscopique
d'envoyer qui gagne le grand prix en
gagnant avec les non c'est pas possible
ouais mais posera qu'à sera dans tous
les cas éligibles à wild card par les
lorrains ont désolé de pas commenté ces
dernières parties j'en profite on a
beaucoup commenté aujourd'hui j'en
profite pour un peu discuté avec vous
j'espère que vous avez ça vous a plu
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à faire des
petits des petits feedback on parle
anglais fait très attention
ce sont des retours au x 5 joly à quel
point ça marche après marche pas du tout
yvonne qui va encore perdre
donc bon match artemiev un nom il faut
qu'ils règlent le problème du fou g8
mais ce sera dans tous les cas la
dernière partie donc là il ya combien il
ya plus cette sage ou pour +8 aura
peut-être qu'ils vont faire nul n'en way
et je crois que avec le petit délai
qu'on a ça doit être la dernière je
pense à moins qu'on en a encore une
je sais pas non c'était bien la dernière
victoire amplement méritée d'arte et
nief qui nous montre toutes ces toutes
ses qualités de leader il a eu l'air
d'être un peu facile et vonn qui a
craqué qui at il dit est en réalité un
il était bien dans le match et puis à ce
moment le moment décisif finalement ça a
été arrêtée le moment il a ou n'a pas pu
réaliser de maths
si vous vous rappelez donc ce qu'on va
faire les amis c'est que on va on va pas
on va enlever la musique je vais laisser
l'écran de pause parce que du coup c'est
mieux comme ça
dans un sens on va finir là-dessus donc
on voit un peu les joueurs qui jouent et
on voit les premières parties et donc ce
que je vais vous dire c'est vous dire
que les prochains matchs sont le 18 et
le 19 vous pouvez toujours trouver les
liens sur chess points comme cela htv
slash fr et du coup ça me permettre ce
lâcher faire ça je t'avais peut-être
dans l'autre sens du coup et ça va me
permettre en plus de faire un de faire
un lien vous pouvez toujours aller
vérifier
tu aies pu voir si le fait sur les cons
comment ça marche quand tu écris sur le
tchat
il y aura les interview sur la chaîne
officielle dont je vous ai mis le lien
les liens dans le chat comme ça vous
avez les dates nepomniachi dingli rennes
donc ce sera lundi très gros match en
perspective
il ya des heures différents arbres mvele
saut
j'ai une heure différente et je checke
créé leur 2ème vl soit et je vous dirai
pas ce que j'ai une heure différente en
fait sur mon truc mais je vais vérifier
ouais non c'est ça ce sera à 16h en fait
lundi nepomniachi contre ding parce que
c'est en chine ces salons de 16h à 19h30
et mardis de 18h à 21h30 winter normale
mardi mais lundi ça devrait être plus
tôt à 16 heures du coup pour le match
n'est peau dingli reine qui sera qui
sera un très beau match aussi à suivre
je suis curieux de voir ding je laisse
la pub des six minutes de pub pour les
gens qui veulent soutenir 13 points
comme quoi même qu'ils nous proposent
toutes ces belles compétitions et nous
on se retrouve très bientôt
merci à tous ciao ciao bye à demain pour
l'aréna et lundi pour pour le match ciao
ciao
[Musique]